foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back in Oslo for the third stop
after Champions Chester and as the
players are getting ready we are making
our way to the studio and here we've got
James Canty James how you feeling I'm
feeling great I got the magnets
James in here David Daniel and Simon
guys I'll be ready yeah
under one minute now for Hikaru and wow
what a move I'll raise her look at him
he's biting his sweatshirt he doesn't
know what to do eight minutes and 59
seconds beaten by one second could you
have swapped Queenstown
immediately any shot oh Magnus has had
no struggles against a car over the
board he should be happy
we have a winner Magnus Carlson takes it
he wins the air things Monsters the very
first event he's training
oh my God
oh and we see a reaction magnets
is the winner of the chessable Masters
Fabiano caruana resigns what an
Armageddon game by Hikaru
[Music]
it's going to be a fierce battle at the
chess cake cup established Elite with
players hungry to prove themselves we
are expecting a lot of decisive games
and to keep you on top of the action in
the studio as always got Master David
Howell
let's go
and joining us for the Chaska cup is
Grandmaster Daniel narodetsky Daniel
it's your first time in Oslo first time
at the studio what are you most looking
forward to first time but hopefully not
my last Tanya it's great to be here it's
really an honor I'm a little bit nervous
but I'm more excited than nervous I'll
do my very best and I know I'm
surrounded by the finest commentators in
the world so it'll be all good it's
gonna be a lot of fun Danny we're so
happy to have you with us and what a
tour it's been so far David you've had
two different winners Magnus Carlsen
took the air tanks Masters Hikaru
Nakamura won the chassisable Masters
what are you expecting from this one
well I'm expecting some drama this time
we don't have the likes of Magnus
Carlson we don't have some of those
other kind of favorites of elite chess
however we have a more open field and uh
there is Hikaru Nakamura that they all
need to get past if they want to win so
it's going to be a great tournament some
new names I'm hoping to etch there uh
yeah names in history
it's gonna be an exciting casket cup
whereas David said with Hikaru Nakamura
now it's hard to bet against him any
tournament he plays he is a favorite he
has been on fire what a performance at
the protest league as well and James
you're a big Hikaru fan I have to ask
you what's it gonna take to get by him I
gotta be 100 honest with you Tanya we
don't know that answer we have no idea
what that takes to beat Hikaru but of
course you just got to play the board
and play as exactly uh whatever the
board gives you right play the board not
the person easier said than done but
that's what it's going to try to take to
be the car
that's some great advice by James do not
let Hikaru Nakamura get into your head
but as he said he said it's easier said
than done well that's the task ahead of
these seven other players let's take a
look at our roster this is our Play Zone
we've got eight players from different
parts of the world and the big breaking
news has been the three last minute
replacement with Jules musad Jordan van
forest and Alexander shimanov playing
division one of the chess kid cup and I
have to ask you Daniel you called the
planes the others can't be too
displeased with the switch up they're
definitely not too displeased with it I
mean icaro alireza Fabi they're kind of
licking their chops looking at those
Alexander shimanas but those very same
Alexander shimanovs and Dimitri callers
they're not just there to gain
experience they're there to score some
upsets they want their name as David
said etched into chess history they want
to be that guy who defeats Hikaru who
defeats Fabiano caruana so it ain't
gonna be an easy Journey for the top
guys
it is indeed their moment to shine will
they be up for it David it is a Fresh
Field you think it also makes it super
unpredictable yeah this uh it's not just
the field that's unpredictable it's the
format Tanya it's been really successful
so far at showcasing Fighting Chess of
course those two favorites Carson and
Nakamura have triumphed but there have
been surprises along the way and I'm
expecting more of the same with these uh
lower ranked players there to make their
mark
and that's exactly what we love about
the Champions Chester it gives talents
and Grandmasters from across the world
their platform to shine and to make sure
that they get the opportunity to compete
against the very best in the world the
Champions Chester is a brand new format
and with two million dollars on the line
This is the biggest season of the tour
to vent in the Champions chess tour is
broken up into three divisions making
the CCT even bigger than ever before as
the best players in the world work to
win their division and progress to
higher divisions hopefully securing a
playoff spot big prize money and Tour
leaderboard points here's what's at
stake in the three divisions in each
event the winner of division three
receives five thousand dollars and 20
tour points those with the most tour
points at Seasons end will secure the
wild card slots for the playoffs and
additional prize money the winner of
division two claims ten thousand dollars
fifty tour points and secures a coveted
slot in the next events division one
finally the winner of division one
receives thirty thousand dollars
150 tour points and a guaranteed spot in
the playoffs at the end the year the
playoffs will include eight players that
have qualified either by winning
division one or by earning enough tour
points to claim one of the wildcard
Slots of these eight players four will
advance to the live finals in the
only one Champion will remain
and to get to that season
s or score those crucial critical door
points and these are our standings going
into the Third Leg of the tour Hikaru
Nakamura so far has been absolutely
tremendous Runners up in the Athens
winning the chassable Masters he leads
behind him Magnus Carlson with 225
points and of course Fabiano caruana who
yet is to qualify for the season finals
some big names there but also the other
side look at that Maxim vasher lagrav
all these players trying to get those
critical tour points so that they can
fight in the season final you've also
got Dan Laz there at the bottom of the
table lots of exciting chess and of
course in this format it's also division
two and three action and to give us all
the updates on that joining us in the
studio will be Ginger DM Grandmaster
Simon Williams Simon welcome has it been
in Osler so far it's been great yeah
um yeah absolutely fantastic I mean Oslo
is a brilliant place and look at the
tour look at the names we had it was a
real who's who of Chess there
absolutely and so
important question
the good night is the world's first ever
chess Pub and I've already popped down
there um of course I have yeah I must
check it out you must check it out
that's just Bob in the world and
playing in division two and three Simon
what stands out to you there's so much
on the line
there is so my job is to keep a look at
these divisions and bring you any
exciting news that comes along so
division two we have some very strong
players in there and let's remind
everyone if you win division two you get
a place in division one which is a
fantastic prize so each day we're going
to take two players and just have a look
at their game see how they're getting on
and today we're going to have a look at
Vladimir fedexv versus The Shack monster
mamajarov two extremely exciting players
there
it is gonna be a big match as the big
fish on chesscom Vladimir photos who has
been on fire he was the MVP of the
protest League takes on the shark attack
and I have to ask you Simon who is the
favorite in your eyes to win division
two this time I'm gonna go mama jarov I
love the way he plays he's really
exciting he loves attacking and uh yeah
I'd love to see him play in the top
division
[Music]
and will be our eyes
for division two and three and there's
division three action as well with some
big names there is indeed so division
three has loads of talent as well uh
you've got lots of youngsters playing I
mean just look at that list of names uh
the two players we're gonna pick today
are gonna be Andrew Tang as our first
player the blitz monster this guy loves
bullet chess he loves playing very quick
online chess and he's playing another
Prodigy Vincent Kamar of Germany so that
game for my eyes is the most tantalizing
uh but there's some other great lineups
as well so young says that give me one
name that stands out to you Simon I'm
well I mean I'm gonna go for Vincent
Kmart again um just because he is a
brilliant talent and he's been playing
so well recently
it's gonna be a lot of fun and
auction we'll be live in a few moments
super excited
side Agnes Carson's Clyde chess or live
on Puma the shoes are out this is your
opportunity to go get your hands on them
Simon great blue suit you're a man of
impeccable style what do you think well
I mean look at these they just look
fantastic don't they they're lovely
white you've even got a cheeky little
King at the start there at the front uh
and yeah I don't know if I'm in a chess
Channel or a shopping channel but uh
they're looking they're looking pretty
cool those things would you guys are on
the desk think about these bad boys I
need those I need magnets let me get 10
and a half my guy I need those ASAP the
real question is what is alireza faroo
did you think about them Gucci resident
is that's right
I love it and is speaking about the
result I'm sure he's gonna love these as
well these are the shoes and it is a
limited drop so while you rush to get
your hands on the MC's let's want to
talk about a player who's been rushing
his way through the world's standings 18
year old naughty back up to satrobe he
is the youngest ever World rapid
champion and he will be making his debut
in division one of the Champions Chester
and it's been a hard to own spot
the Champions chess tour is not just
about the top division oh no not only
does the division 2 winner advance to
the top tier of the next event but
points to qualify for the final are
available plus the cash is nice at the
chessable Masters the second event of
the tour division two Was Won by
notrebec abisitorov the 2021 World rapid
Champion started The Knockout rounds the
quick sweep of Anish giri this looks
very over next the young Grandmaster
from Uzbekistan had to defeat two of his
fellow teenage phenoms Arjun era geisi
and Dennis lazovic in a lot of trouble
very impressive by the young man French
Legend Maxim vashieller was abusatorov's
opponent for each of the teens last two
rounds in a classic Battle of Youth vs
experience youth won this time as with
Geary abdusitorov needed just three
games to advance in their first match
mvl then had to earn the rematch by
first defeating Geary himself in the
losers final but abdusitorov held him
off yet again to clinch the division
having secured a division one spot at
the chess kid cup how will abdisatorab
do there who will win the second
division this time around there's only
one way to find out
not available
[Music]
ambition and motivation will be at an
all-time high now to start with we will
be focusing on Hikaru Nakamura taking on
Jordan ban Forest I'm gonna start by you
Daniel what are you expecting from
Hikaru in the opening he starts with
white oh Hikaru likes to be solid uh for
a while he was playing Knight F3 on move
one almost exclusively in these
tournaments recently he switched more to
E4 he can basically play anything he
likes to start solid I don't even think
he Minds a draw that much in the first
game Jordan is the one who will really
have to lean into his famed opening
preparation Tanya everything will have
to go right for the Dutch Prodigy if he
wants to score a shock upset in round
one
for the Dutch Grandmaster it is going to
be a tough day in office but Jordan
landfur is this known for his creative
style his offbeat openings and that's
what we're so excited to see and guys
once again I'm looking at the feel and
James I want to ask you what are the
chances of us getting another Hikaru
Fabi Final in this one oh the chances
are high but of course I mean with this
field I mean it's creative it's lots of
competition it's hard everybody's going
to be going at each other I mean we even
see Magnus go down artemia at one point
right so we really can't call it all the
way but it is a it's a good chance that
we may see a car World Poppy
it is a big day of chess for the players
and speaking of Fabiano caruana he is
fresh out of his win at the super bet in
Romania he is in form he takes on
shimanov David what are you expecting
from that one shimanov is super solid he
has a great repertoire and he's actually
a blitz and Rapid specialist he plays a
lot of line he streams it's not going to
be easy for Fabiano but if Fabiana
strikes first uphill struggle for his
opponent
door points on the line the golden
ticket to the in-person season final and
of course the player who wins the Chaska
cup will also win the chess Champs
Trophy and chat we've got big news for
you there will be two editions of the
trophy one for the winner and one will
be The Fan Edition this is the beautiful
piece of digital art that will go out
and you can start your bid on chesscom
dot IO and this is the cool part you get
a VIP ticket to the in-person season
final Hikaru Nakamura Magnus Carlson
have already punched that ticket James
how cool will it be to watch the
in-person finals oh that's gonna be
great in person fights the finals and in
person come on right that's gonna be
amazing you want that kind of energy you
want that kind of Chess and you want to
be a part of it
really is and we can hear the clock
ticking which you know what that means
that the games will be underway super
soon we see the players are ready
and Jordan van Forest they're looking
pretty serious right now he looks
delighted Jordan is so happy to be here
he's happy with his easy round one
pairing Tanya
stress just straight up Knight F35 yeah
and uh Daniel was right Nakamura
starting with Knight F3 he tends to do
this but it has transposed to a queen uh
Pawn opening here symmetry so far any
predictions London system Queen's Gambit
we think he's thinking B3
Tanya it's your fault
oh you've jinxed it Tanya the London
system which has experienced a surgeon
popularity dingler end one a game at the
world championship with it everyone's
playing it these days what do we think
Jordan must have prepared this before he
studied with Magnus Carlson who tends to
drop the London system from time to time
any uh kind of surprises in the opening
stages what do we think yeah I'm not
familiar with Hikaru even playing in
London I've never ever ever seen him
play London system so here I was
definitely therefore you can play
anything obviously but it's gonna be
cool to see what he tries to come up
with of course he can play any type of
position he could already right so I
mean so far so good very solid stuff as
we did see that Surge from the world
championship of uh Dean winning the
London game so the London is perfectly
playable for a win at any level here so
curious to see what happens in the rest
of this game yeah this has been his Mo
in Rapid tournaments in particular he
likes to get sort of semi-theoretical
positions he doesn't play stuff that's
too offbeat no polish openings from
hikaranakamura something in the middle
right something where he's got the
flexibility to play a nice maneuvering
game but really the the London has
become very theoretical in recent years
you really can't call it an offbeat
opening anymore can you yeah there's so
many forcing lines uh often calculated
out to move 20 even Beyond we've seen
some of the top players in the world
take this turn it into a really
dangerous weapon from the white side and
I am slightly surprised I've got to say
if Jordan pausing to think he must have
two or three different ideas against the
London and eventually he has decided to
bring his Queen out porn hunting it's a
dangerous dangerous profession in
general but black neglecting development
if he goes and grabs that B2 Pawn next
how will Nakamura decide uh to react
what do we think is he going to gamble
to pawn is he gonna maybe take a more
solid approach just defend that pawn on
B2
okay meanwhile we change games let's
leave the car to think about that one
and Forest does
or the most dynamic
so London
handles that question of the beat upon
hanging we are getting action from
karwana Fabiano caruana taking on
Alexander shimanov and wow at 3 A6
are you guys shocked
does tend to avoid opening Theory I
guess because he's not as active a
player as some of these top guys
actually I was researching he has barely
played a classical game since before the
pandemic but uh it is risky to take
Fabiano on uh to kind of provoke him in
this manner this poor move does not
necessarily improve Black's position no
I mean as chess fans we're also jaded
about opening now and nothing surprises
anymore H5 on move three A6 on move four
we're just basically immune to these
types of moves because nowadays you know
the computer makes anything possible A6
is not an unknown waiting move it's
pretty popular against the move Knight
to D2 the torash variation so I'm pretty
sure that we're still well within uh
some sort of opening Theory and here we
see Fabi dropping his Knight back very
common strategy as well in order to
secure that pawn chain with C3
probably has some great success with the
French here especially with this line I
remember seeing uh moves obviously uh or
games always played Knight F4 here H4
Rook H3 believe it or not and moving the
bishop to E2 or D3 and putting the King
on F1 there it is Knight F4 immediately
the engine is like what are you doing
that's like a move that's crazy how the
engine just didn't like it at all but
definitely as we've seen this before
whoa G5 relax you're gonna have to relax
my guy this is the chess kid cup we got
kids watching G5 Daniel what is that
I've been Fabby missed this move G5 is a
knife right in the back side that pawn
isn't stopping there it's going to G4
kicking the other night away Tanya Abby
has to be careful not to lose his entire
Center I mean Knight takes D4 is right
up there Fabby might have to drop his
Knight back to E2 and uh we gotta get
away from that game
Fabiano in trouble potentially but uh
now for Russia against Dimitri kolas and
this game has progressed as well it's a
Catalan opening black has grabbed a pawn
black is temporarily a pulling up but
white has the bishop pair white has the
potential for a very strong Pawn early
thoughts on this game
what do you thinking Daniel what you got
here yeah it's one of those typical
nondescript Catalan positions where
White's given up the customary pawn and
he's got the bishop here he's got a
little bit of a better Center but the
issue is if you fall asleep then what
does black want to do well black ones
played B7 B5 right that's why he put the
Rook on V8 to get out of the pin and if
he deploys the bishop to B7 very often
you look up and suddenly you don't
really have compensation for the pawn so
it's the ball very much in faruges chord
and there we see him actively trying not
to cooperate preventing B5 yeah it feels
like a Frugal type of position at least
it's got huge Dynamic potential yes he's
a pawn down but he's not too
materialistic and if black isn't able to
uh kind of activate unravel and either
maintain the pawn or get his pieces out
sufficiently then I think Advantage
white so uh promising signs at this
early game at this early point in the
game and uh yeah of the games we've seen
so far the opening positions which one
do you think has the most potential
definitely a G5 one that G5 G he played
G5 casually you know he's sitting back
in the chair relaxing just play G5 like
it was nothing no I did see a it was an
ag5 and Knight E6 like was that possible
Diane of course right 95.99
I don't like what you're implying here
we're aggressive players ourselves here
so we definitely will talk about this
type of stuff Knight G5 I think was
there in 96 and Knight to C7 some crazy
lines in that but here uh yeah I think
uh faruja has obviously a great position
you have the cattle in with the bishop
on G2 I mean these positions that even
Magnus has played all the way through
right so you know it's a little bit of
life here
there is live all
ointment hunting G5 on another board and
in the last one as well black is up upon
already and this is the fourth game that
will be lifting up really soon as not
the back of the Statue of takes on Jules
Musa to aggressive Fighters with the
white pieces are we expecting another
back to start with one E4
before I tell you the answer to that
question you know what Jules likes with
his burger what do you like ketchup and
massage
all right wow we can talk about the
chest now I'll allow it
um not Rebecca's played everything he
likes C4 on move one as well but uh I
think his first move will reveal his
intentions in in large part David yeah
completely agree and uh very quickly
though we do see it is E4 and open
Sicilian and wow add some spice to that
mustard Burger Queen takes D4 coming out
early and uh okay provocative stuff this
has uh experienced a bit of uh well a
lot of attention actually at the top
levels lately just bringing the queen
out and aiming to just develop as
quickly as possible but a surprise for
sure for moosad here up to satorov you
mentioned the English opening and others
anytime he's done he kind of puts his
stamp on a opening it tends to really
take off and he must have come prepared
with ideas just developing his Bishop
here very calm stuff uh early days but
musad the first one to really tank the
first one to start thinking at this uh
this point in the Sicilian yeah this
one's is uh there's a straight like the
plans are very nice here pintala Gary
krishnash she likes to play this with
why you play this a lot and actually he
likes to play Queen E3 after an ic6
Bishop D2 ended up casting on the queen
side there so really quick development
castling and getting The Rook to D1
sometimes you can even just Castle Queen
E3 and then put a rook on D1 so very
very uh fun I think this is yeah there's
the queen E3 move right so very fun I
think it is from White's point of view
but black definitely is just pretty
solid I'm not even gonna lie G6 Bishop
G7 and move the queen castle like you
don't have many problems here so we're
gonna see what a absucator off has up is
up his sleeve in the next few moves here
yep so let's start to this game looks
like yeah they're still blitzing out the
moves anti-sicilians more popular than
ever as players just trying to avoid
theory in this line the theory of this
line is really built up uh over the last
couple of years but Notre back just kind
of trying to get a normal standard
strategic position castling to safety on
the king side and jealous the first to
take a bit of a think here
but it's been amazing to see the kind of
unique openings that we've been seeing
at the very start on all these four
boards and how important is it to get
your opponent to think early on in these
formats it is important and it's
important to put your stamp on the mini
match really in the very first game
because there's obviously the results
but there's also the psychological flow
of the match and especially if you're
the lower rated player if you can catch
your opponent off guard in game one
Tanya that's exactly what Alexander
shimanov is doing he's not playing E4 E5
and trying to make a grinded out draw
he's playing for a win in game one and I
think that is the approach which gives
you the best chances as the lower rated
player
and meanwhile uh we see Fabiano caruana
and uh this was the game French defense
some quick moves there we joined it a
few moments ago when G5 landed on the
board now look at Carolina's Knights
they've undeveloped they've retreated
clumsy ugly development for white but
has black overextended I'm loving
Black's position I've got to say Queens
out uh Knight's looking good but what
next H3 fabi's trying to developers
Rooks Rooks before Knights and Bishops
conventional chess wisdom but what do we
think here I'm skeptical for white I'll
try this at home with the uh developing
your Rooks first chat but at the same
time here I'm actually a fan of black
too as well here I've been mentioning
this lately a lot of the commentaries
you've been seeing a lot of French at
eye level definitely origin in the
Indian teams as well and PCO been using
a French a lot but I have noticed that
in Fringe games usually the middle games
are the most tactical you'll ever see in
fact even sometimes more tactical than
Sicilians so here as you see this is a
wacky position I mean G file open F7 is
weak like where do you put the king for
blaming plays E5 like this is a wild
game you wouldn't never think you would
get that from a friend's defense but in
fact it definitely is much so so I
definitely take black hair don't you
yeah me too I mean you don't even have
to ask me you know who I'm going to be
here but Alexander he's following basic
chess principles when you've got the
lead in development strike in the center
try to open up files and you know one
more mistake and Fabiano could very well
get checkmated there in the center
there's no question the black is
overextended himself he's got a lot of
weaknesses that could be revealed if
white is able to complete his
development but man I don't think Fabio
was expecting challenges of this kind
five minutes into the first game with
the white pieces I'm talking in five
minutes he's almost five minutes down on
the clock he's under 10 minutes uh
Fabian danger already who would have
expected this I said it beforehand
shimanov don't write him off he's so
dangerous and normally he's a more
strategic positional player but he's
sensing the moment he's going for a
quick kill here as black and I've never
seen such a such a good french defense
I've got to admit yeah especially by
move for 10 15 uh of a game and yeah you
can tell body language as well Fabby
really struggling so far
very ambitious played there by Alexander
Shimano he starts with the French
defense please a 3 A6 on one side of the
board and then we saw him marching down
with that jeep on really taking control
of the squares for Fabi to develop his
Knight and look at White's position all
the pieces still on the first rank the
only developed piece is that white
knight which has jumped around the board
multiple times and that hasn't helped
fabi's cause he's down on the clock and
currently with the black pieces it looks
like shimanov is in driving seat a
decision has been made to capture the E5
pawn and now to me it looks like the
obvious choice would be to recapture
with the Knight the chimarov takes a
little bit of a think and David what are
you expecting a queen E5 or a 95 from
him oh yeah both look attractive to me
Tanya I've got to say taking with the
queen does have the benefit that it pins
this Black Knight sorry the White Knight
on E2 meaning that it's harder for white
to develop you do have to calculate
perhaps White's Bishop coming out but
then the pawn would drop on B2 and to me
everything looks great for black like
taking with the Knights does feel like
you might get an opportunity later to
drop in with a quick check if you can
bring more pieces in to support the
attack so either way it's looking good
here for blackened at this point I think
shimanov with a huge time Advantage
already it makes sense for him to start
thinking which way are we voting here
Dania James
I don't know and I hate these situations
particularly against the high rated I've
burned almost my entire clock you have
two options both of them look good you
start getting stressed out because you
know that this is an early chance right
you mess up now you might not get a
chance like this again in the black
pieces my vote
um I don't know I would say queen takes
E5 that was my gut feeling to prevent
the development of white Stark Square
Bishop David is you astutely pointed out
aiming at the B2 Pawn James yeah
okay okay I got to go with Queen because
I was going to say night but I'm going
to say queen because I cannot just
disagree with the Prophet Daniel but at
the same time I did like Knight takes E5
because there's just some random weird
stuff like Bishop f593 like kind of
where do you move I mean I was also
looking of course this is a long shot
but like Knight F3 is a mate now of
course you can't get it's going to be a
hard thing to do but like a strange line
would be like David just to show it g
takes H3 right let's just say or uh
let's do um H takes G right H takes G
okay yep Ace takes G right and then um
something like I don't know we have to
figure out how to get his Knight to F3
right I'll just make one variation I
don't take this right yeah right but I
was also thinking Queen F3 right if he
develops his Knight at some point and
then Knight F3 getting hot in here oh
yeah of course
the queen F3 at some point like if he
develops his Knight we say the idea is
there right that's what we're seeing
that's why I like Knight takes E5 it's
very fun but Queen takes E5 probably is
the move and that sucks on the board by
the way yeah he went the other way he
took with the queen and uh off to point
export I'm expecting a quick recapture
on G4 uh from Black's bishop and again
developing with Tempo I'm struggling to
see fabi's next few moves I've got to
admit this is out against one
disgusting I think Knight F3 is an
incredibly strong move though both
positionally and tactically because
looks like black snaps off on F3 but
that gives white sudden tactical chances
black takes and castles Queen side there
are some ideas where the light squared
Bishop can now develop to H3 and then
the dark Square Bishop from C1 to F4 and
you can lose the lady here really really
quickly so I think Shima might have
underestimated this move Knight F3 it
poses them with another dilemma David
now he's got to burn more clock to
figure out if he gives up the bishop or
not Fabby getting back on his feet here
yeah great move and a lot of us a lot of
players at home myself included we would
be thinking okay this is ugly we allow a
set of double pawns what is our King
doing in the center what are these pawns
uh long term in the end game but
sometimes you have to use these small
tricks to gain time to force your
opponent to think and at least white
does have the long-term advantage of the
bishop pair too so really classy stuff
this is the current position and yeah at
least one question uh one difficult
question actually for Shimano to answer
for the first time in this game and as
we see the clock situation is also
getting Level as Shimano of takes I
think in this position Sabi with that
trade the minor piece trade does intend
to develop his pieces with Tempo that
Bishop landing on H3 with a check the
other Bishop coming to attack the black
queen and it looks like Fabi can breathe
a sigh of relief and while he does just
that we've got action on in the alireza
farouja colors mode and that's the one
that I want to pull up and get your
attention to we did see a Catalan
position where Dmitry did go get greedy
picked up the C4 Pawn alireza has
managed to win it back and how do we
assess this because very often in the
Catalan if black gets a good E5 break he
solved all his problems yeah that's
normally true but here there are some
extenuating circumstances White's got
the bishop pair and alirez has managed
to recapture the C4 Pawn Tanya so if you
look at those Queen side pawns on A6 and
on C7 those pawns are weak I think
alireza has not a huge Advantage but
definitely slight plus this is exactly
what you want out of a Catalan and we
see he takes D4 so we're gonna get some
more Transformations And Trades here
maybe the black queen can come out to D5
and offer a queen trade but Dimitri has
to tread very carefully here no question
about it yeah quick move there from
Dimitri plonking his Knight in the
center of the board aiming to reduce uh
White's Advantage potentially by
capturing one of the Bishops but no
frugier instantly repeat uh kind of
reacting by bringing his Bishop to
Target the backward and isolated C7 pawn
and yeah these two black knights they
look kind of nice but they do feel
clumsy at the same time and uh farouza
just I love the pace he's keeping both
players playing very fast actually uh at
this moment in time and it looks like
one-way traffic to me yes you all have
isolated pawns but white has the easier
targets yeah I think white has a huge
practical Advantage I mean the engine's
like oh yeah I like waited just a little
bit right but practically I mean we have
the Bishops pointing at the queen side
you have everything you want in a
Catalan now of course black does have
the bishop opposing the light Square
Bishop on G2 in the Catalan the light
Square Bishop on G2 is an absolute
monster but you when you can oppose it
with Bishop B7 or sometimes the early
Bishop D7 to C6 even a move like this
Knight before saying yo bro we gotta get
that Bishop off the board here but what
a mogul hey B4 he just put it right
there out there like that what happens
if I take well Dimitri just taking the
bull by the horns or shall I say the
position by the caller
forget I said anything Queen takes
before the idea is Bishop B7 takes F3
that's what's called a discovered attack
for newer players that's when a piece
moves out of the way and opens up an
attack on another piece in this case The
Rook attacks the queen so you can't take
back on F3 the more trades the less
Machinery white has to Target those
Queen side pawns the better black stand
so I think alireza will have to find a
way to restrict the mobility of that
Knight and prevent it from jumping to D3
Tanya yeah I love it night before such a
tactical way to try to solve problems
and as you're mentioning there is the
trick of capturing on F3 but not just
that there is a big threat on the board
as well that Knight on B4 wants to land
on the D3 square and just neutralize the
bishop pair that we've been talking
about that is a big Trump in alireza's
position some creative play there by
Dimitri kolas with his last move and one
of the create of players in this field
is Jordan van Forrest he's playing
against Hikaru Nakamura there is hot
action on that one as well we do see a
lot of trade one second where are we
missing
where is his Queen where is his Queen
okay guys uh how good is your accounting
we need to do some counting here what is
the material balance black has lost this
queen but in return has a rook Knight
and Pawn
I think so it looks like level material
uh if you do a bit of counting there but
what do we think actually I quite like
Jordan's position I've got to say is
black put great potential just to
install knights in the center of the
board and full blockade the White Queen
lacking any activity at the moment
the dream compensation for the queen
Kenny Knights on F5 and D5 kikaru could
get crushed around the first rank I mean
evalvar giving a very modest Plus for
black
but I like what I'm seeing here from
Jordan
that's crazy very creative as we think
we always plays very crib G3 that is not
a move engine it's like yo that's Garbo
start a new one immediately actually
what is the move here G3 maybe it's just
Knight D5 or Rook C3 hits G3 okay we
move the queen
I love it from you and he's going to
start switching his attention towards
the white king side uh those white pawns
really loose just plump plant tonight on
D5 I don't think you need to even worry
too much about those Queen side pawns
for black and uh Hikaru are you
impressed by how calm he looks I've been
terrified here for you yeah
I mean he wins about 97.8 of these types
of positions so I think he already has
the narrative established in his mind
he's gonna get you guarded on low on
time he's going to start getting nervous
and so important for Jordan to avoid
that maybe go H5 H4 that's a canty-like
idea break down White's pawns or Knight
D5 but David icaro asking some questions
here and Orson Gordon to sacrifice some
more pawns which he does yeah H5
definitely happened too that's crazy H5
H4 is going forward I mean yeah the
problem here is that okay yes I do have
the extra Queen quotation marks here but
look at the piece the quality bishop and
Knight look pretty gross I'm just
defending I have a rook on D1 doing what
exactly right just defending the D4 Pawn
it's not really active here the queen is
definitely going to have to be by
herself in many cases here definitely
black has huge compensation here what a
queen sack um from Jordan here wow
creative 100 create creative and
effective here just uh I mean I'm
dreaming of a night landing on this
Quest never ever going to get challenged
and I'm not even calculating here if I'm
Jordan I don't think he needs to just
start motoring forward towards that
white king and there we go the night
lands you've got to be really worried
now this Pawn push is going to break
down the white defenses this Pawn is
going to be gone and what is White Queen
doing off on a limb on her own terrible
position for what to look like and
that's the big question right you've got
the queen on one side of the board all
the other pieces on the other end the
bishop on F2 not playing a role at all
if that Bishop was on E5 we probably
would have been singing to another tune
that would be activity but it looks like
it's Jordan who's got all the play in
the position and what I love is the
speed with which he's playing we don't
often get to see Hikaru Nakamura with
the white pieces the absolute Beast one
of the best players in the world down
two minutes on the clock and facing the
pressure but let's not forget this is
one of the most resourceful if not the
most resilient player on the planet he's
not gonna make it easy right now a clear
threat he is delaying H4 he is hitting
that Rook on C3 and notice how that Rook
on C3 needs to stay connected to that
other Rook where do you move
good question and a tricky move as you
say that Tanya I would never have this
on my radar retreating a bishop from a
nice defensive post but he is asking
questions and Jordan maybe he just
reinstalls his Rook on the second rank
Rooks can be so deadly there uh if you
keep them connected you could drop back
and gain some time against the White
Queen but there we go he plants his Rook
on C2 and still the threats remain those
Black Knights are hinting at jumping in
already and uh how does Nakamura react
how do you keep kind of prolonging this
defensive setup I mean he's got to try
to get a pair of Rooks off the board but
that's much easier said than done
because Rook D2 would be met with Rook
C1 and black will start picking those
minor pieces off the first drink another
idea that's causing angst is Rook B8 and
then the Rooks could double on the
second rank H5 H4 that was the initial
idea any car says I don't care about any
of that I literally don't care he's just
grabbing pawns and making Jordan prove
it and we're about to enter a very
exciting phase of the game wow very
dangerous this is very dangerous for the
chess case at home right maybe sure you
close your eyes on this one this is a
family channel this is definitely about
to get crazy here he went to this bishop
back to E1 eval bars all the way in
Black's favor here and Bishop E1 the
Jordan play paying for immediate
compensation does he now double on the
seventh rank or 90
. so many good-looking moves ah so many
here you mentioned Daniel Knight H4
looks brutal just jumping in with some
check mating ideas evaluation bar still
stays in Black's Camp so this is
extremely strong you could jump the
other way you could jump into this
Square this looks killer as well I've
got to say you can start picking off
pawns this Pawn is ripe uh to be plucked
and also uh Daniel you mentioned just
doubling the Rooks bringing them to the
second rank your support for Choice
maybe that's the only uh potential
Hazard for Jordan five minutes but five
or six good moves to choose from
dude I've seen everything I've seen a
car win every type of position but this
is completely winning and six minutes as
an eternity to figure out these are
obvious mating patterns now Knight F3
whichever way you run you get mated King
H1 Rook H2 Arabian mate King F1 95 to E3
let's call it called the Jordan Ren
Forest mate and you don't need that Rook
on C you don't need that Bishop the
knights and the other Rook they do the
heavy lifting here David oh this is
painful wow painful and so aesthetically
pleasing this is visually striking from
Jordan so far Queens they are the
strongest piece but if she is so far
away from the defense of a king like uh
like hikaru's Queen right now then
actually yeah they can't fight against
the might of several pieces combined and
look at those two black knights look at
these nice I see Carl says himself and
it backfires as these Knights is
definitely cooking right now in the
white Camp here Knight takes H3 is there
I mean like F3 I mean anything three
Rook B8 to B2 like it's so many moves
here even sometimes even play F5 trying
to get rid of the Knight some cases sack
to Bishop there's so many things to do
here this is definitely difficult even
for a resourceful player Like You cover
the change with Hikaru it's not over
till it's over 94 does Hit that if
you've seen big turnarounds and he does
make the impossible possible but this
position now for Jordan one first it's
so important to keep the pressure on the
clock to take those decisions quickly
but is this a good moment for him to
slow down and calculate it till the very
end to pick the right choices does he
jump with the F4 Knight to H3 does he
land on F3 with a check is this time for
Jordan to slow down a little it is and
he has to because I've been looking at
this position for a minute and I don't
actually see a super convincing move
Knight takes H3 King F1 and for the
moment whites King is dodging the
biggest bullets he gives a check with
the other night the eval bar creeps up
this is what always seems to happen in
hikaru's games you make one little
mistake and then you start feeling
nervous I think after King H1 that
Knight on F3 is in the Queen's
crosshairs 94 to F6 check as well as
Knight takes Bishop become the threats I
think Jordan might be losing control
already wow yeah you do fear for Jordan
here just because of hikara's track
record just because of the fact that now
it's actually uh far narrower the path
towards Victory the margin of error for
black suddenly is high and I would be
blundering here against Hikaru one of
the two black knights is gonna drop off
the White Queen is going to do some
damage commentators curse I said it
earlier the white Queen's doing nothing
but something feels a bit loose now for
Jordan okay he grabs a pawn and Hikaru
keeps some measure of control he's very
good at consolidating Hikaru just
surviving asking the opponent to find
those difficult moves and he looks ugly
for white still but this defensive setup
for now is holding what does Jordan have
to do does he take a time out his Bishop
is attacked you mentioned Daniel this
threat of Knight F6 check the White
Queen picking up the Black Knight on F3
everything's really loose this is such a
misleading evil bar because Bishop D6 to
f8 would be like the move I'd play in a
bullet game but then Knight F6 check and
white picks off the Knight on F3 you get
a massive liquidation and then at the
end White's got that past Apon which
could be really unpleasant and time
pressure I'm not seeing The Knockout
blow this might be one of those
positions David where you have to find a
narrow path to Victory and if you don't
find it you're basically not even better
agent like look at that you see it says
Rook C3 wow
I'm assuming no ways you're gonna find
that Rook to C3 giving up his Bishop
what is the idea and The Rock too I
thought the same thing oh and The Rook
wow okay I didn't even see this one it's
uh this is crazy just giving up the Rook
so that you can capture this bishop and
either the white King has to walk
forward I'm assuming there's a knockout
blow here maybe to do with some nasty
Checkmate wow
oh my goodness oh my goodness no chance
sir Jordan's gonna find this with five
minutes but this is beautiful stuff uh
so either you take this way or you get
checkmated in a different fashion I
guess and two nights two Rooks against
the lone white king but this is
incredibly difficult to spot do we think
he's gonna find it oh my God engine says
only one other move to maintain the
advantage that's difficult too dropping
your Bushman four yeah it looks like a
bit of a nothing move so margin for
error now for Jordan tiny is he gonna
find one of these two moves Bishop by
four or even more powerful Rook C3 you
know what's funny I actually spotted
Rook C3 but I was like I don't even know
what I'm doing I'm just gonna put the
rigor on C3 it looks great but like
what's like what do you do afterwards
you have to spot Knight F2 knight uh
back to uh H4 and like that is
ridiculous just Wicked calculation there
after Rook C3 Knight D6 is probably a
little bit easier but man the Knight C3
thing and it's just it's too much it's a
lot here to him for him to find
especially at the time right now having
a thinking for two minutes having two
and a half just under now and Bishop F40
other move like what does that even do
right it's just very difficult to figure
this out here yeah crazy two minutes now
for Jordan he has to realize that this
white knight is overloaded and actually
cannot move uh in any effective way but
uh okay he didn't find this one he's
played as king to G7 and the game goes
on now uh still a total mess I guess his
ideas potentially swing his Rook over to
hit the white king but Hikaru according
to the computer at least is back in it
yeah yeah in it yeah yeah I'm back in
the game where do you even move like
what do I do king G2 he eats both the
knights maybe what is this thing right
oh my goodness yeah like just take the
bishop rook h8 and hope for the best
yeah we saw the engine suggestions
earlier maybe we can see them again how
how many moves does Hikaru have to
survive he took the bishop super
talenting but now black winning again
is there so I thought Rook takes F2 is
very strong here but then maybe black
can actually take back on F2 allow the
queen to capture on F7 and maybe somehow
the king Dodges all the checks through
H6 I'm not sure though it's pretty gross
that's it Queen F4 okay and then King H5
and there are no checks look at that oh
but never mind but now this is defended
this check so maybe take the road so you
have to play G5 first okay and force the
queen away from the defensive H2 oh
you're right yeah and now King H5 oh my
goodness check and you keep running
keep running forward and where do we
hide check we need four and King G3 and
the queen takes the square away from the
knights is crazy so uh we could be
seeing a King march here but Jordan has
to calculate this a car who has to
calculate this this was definitely his
plan right Danielle James Rook takes
Knight and uh going in for this
variation but the only option now is
potentially to bring your king forward
into the firing line of this black Rook
looks disastrous for white right now
gotta say
[Music]
huh is there a it has to be everybody
you have to find it at a minimum black
and play Knight F2 to E4 and then pick
off the Knight on D6 and then right it's
target practice against White's King so
Jordan's got that in his pocket I think
he car just calculated that line as
reflected by him sitting back in disgust
but Jordan's got a lot of bullets to
dodge even if Hikaru takes on F2 David
the game's not over there yeah the
game's not over and you can tell Jordan
looking very focused leaning forward on
his camera he's still trying to work
that out he's hoping it works out for
black and we know from that variation
from the analysis that it does work out
for black but uh Jordan he's not going
to be sure Hikaru coming to that
realization what's he gonna do I think
walking forward with the King loses in
several ways so you pretty much have to
take that Knight and just pray just
cross your fingers and hope but Hikaru
devastated he's realizing now that he is
crashing to defeat with white in the
first game of the day yeah we're not
coming out there shaking his head he's
down to a minute on the clock in a
position that looks absolutely busted
and as you mentioned the only move to go
up with that King to G2 will Jordan run
for us find the kill of law he seems to
be doing everything right what a great
game with the black pieces so far he
will pick up that Knight on D6 and the
other Rook comes into the attack is this
game over no
if it wasn't Hikaru we would say game
over but it is hikaranakamura and uh
maybe he'll find one way to at least
prolong the game for some accuracy from
Jordan Daniel are you sure it looks like
game over to me King F4 and you still
have to find that mating and I've been
in this situation a million times where
you're like all chess principles tell
you that there's 500 mates but you're
actually looking and you cannot find a
single mating construction maybe F6 and
G5 is the way to force the king onto the
H file but Rogue G1 Rook F2 King G4 I
mean it's so easy to make that one wrong
move yeah it should be made but a couple
more accurate moves required from Jordan
yeah this is one thing I think everyone
should note at home don't lead from the
front with your king you will get
checkmated especially if there are heavy
pieces on the board but Daniel you're
right so far Richie won he's prolonging
the tension
no matter what the bar says he still has
to prove it Jordan can he deliver the
killing blow I don't see it yet either
I've got to say on G5 and King G6 I
think that was amazing I think it's
early F5 right F5 Knight F7 Rick H3
something like that 30 seconds for
Hikaru King G4 has been played Jordan
vanfur is looking confident and Hikaru
looking like he's giving up but you know
we all know that we can't get fooled by
hikaru's expression well actually Tanya
Hikaru has resigned he didn't even ask
Jordan that final question he didn't
even ask him to deliver the Checkmate he
just resides and storms off wow
resigns in a position Daniel you said
it's still game on are you surprised
with this early abrupt ending oh it's
just that you already has two minutes
and when I look at this a little more
deep I am surprised the car resigned I
think he's just disgusted by the way the
game went but F5 check here forces the
king onto a square where it can be
checked by either the look or the knight
at this point I mean it's almost
impossible to mess this up for black so
I get it Hikaru kept it close but Jordan
with nerves us but still Tanya what an
amazing game by Jordan van forest and
the other big favorite Fabiano Carana it
looks like he's the one in driving seat
in this position look at that black king
that's got to be a Checkmate soon yeah
let him Rook chat let him Rook okay that
man's cooking right now it's about to be
mating like two right made in three some
Queen F4 Rook G7 and then like just hit
hit the button I mean Rook G1 Queen F4
Rook G1 hit the button which is the
resign button yeah but okay Queen F4
Queen E5 even better Queen F4 was Queen
F5 so Queen E5 but now Rook F3 oh wow
look it's a Precision Mr calculator
that's probably for you of course the
most precise way to do it GG
this is amazing and we see the two Rooks
and the Queen the power of the major
pieces and one of the majors here at the
chess gate cup Fabiano caruana takes the
first win in his match against Shimano
it started super shaky for Fabi well
action is on on the other boards as well
and we see our eval bar Dimitri colas in
a crushing position against alireza
farusha while Abdul satro looks like
he's about to take the win what do you
guys want to head to definitely gotta go
to Gucci residents well something
happened not anymore eval bar just
jumped there it definitely jumped colors
was it like he was winning based off the
event bar once we get to the game and
now it's back to equal must be in some
time scrambles here wow crazy stuff
first it was actually a whole Rook down
in that game I think we'll jump over
there in a moment or two sure was a rook
down about to crash his feet but call us
panicked maybe with little time on his
clock and it's level again it's queen
versus two Rook suddenly and uh okay
actually we're in with Abdi sator of and
musad and uh this one if we do a quick
count white has six pawns black has only
five so white temporarily are pulling up
white with a safer King looks like
winning for Abdul Satora of this one
actually every game we've seen Queen and
heavy pieces and often a checkmating
attack maybe we'll see the same in this
one too
smooth this is just winning from all
sides whites of material the king is
permanently weak on h8 Queen is coming
to E5 this one's game set well not games
that match just game for now what a good
start from just a tour of yeah with that
extra Pawn on the weekend you need one
Rook left either the D1 road goes to D3
or the A1 road goes a 283 joins the
attack and obvious Auto definitely
looking good on this one he's also up on
the clock the extra pawn it doesn't
matter Black's got to spend some time if
he wanted to pick that up but that would
mean danger for the king Jules will
start trying to bring that Rook into the
defense he's looking at covering the
seventh Rank and maybe going Rook G7
trying to hide that King block it do you
think it's going to be enough
hiding your king is one thing you're
also pulled down temporarily you're
gonna get uh kind of left with ruinous
pawns I'm assuming white sticks is going
to trade in the center here take on D5
with your opponent you're left with four
isolated uh little guys there which are
gonna be weak are going to be targeted
so it feels like everything is wrong and
uh even if you survive to an end game
you will lose that to First a check from
Abdul sotorov and next move he'll get
ready to start picking some more pawns
off the board now so the position is
just collapsing here trying to figure
out what's the most accurate way I mean
you can even do Rook A6 you also can do
pawn takes uh D5 here of course it may
be a queen B6 but then we have a pass
Pawn again which is by pushing D6 Pawn
it's pushing it up we can go Rook A3 to
G3 Queen is centralized black has no
real play here very tough game also 39
seconds this one is a wrap I like the
look of C5 to deflect the Queen off that
long diagonal and then take on A6 I
definitely so uh Queen C5 over k6 yeah
okay I was trying to figure out what
happened on Queen C5 okay exactly nice
very nice and B7 is also a threat so
many you know all roads lead to touch
can't here but
you know in outer Bank this is this is
easy easy clapping he's enjoying this
yeah definitely and two minutes more
than enough time for the young uh
respect player here he can play any move
pretty much and win pushing forward
taking this Pawn taking this pawn and uh
he should have this one in the bag we
saw a tough start to the day for him as
well uh it looks like some very very
strong play from one of the two players
in all of these matchups so far not
gonna say one-sided but uh really
inspired attacking play especially and
uh yeah it's hard to imagine black
surviving this one I just can't imagine
any world in which you uh Klingon and
even get to that end game get to a rook
end game Rook takes Pawn first of all
Dania looks just as good yeah I mean
Black's gonna play D take C4 and ooh
he's gonna make a maiden one thread
something tells me Notre back is going
to see that and he did what a big
surprise there right and massard's
counter play has been exhausted Rook A7
is Unstoppable he'll probably try King
G8
but Rook A7 nonetheless Rook D6 just
lift a piece and put it on any square
and you're going to be winning yeah
White's Queen is so dominant this is
just the most beautiful queen you will
ever see uh this is one thing to
remember at home just centralize your
Queens in uh these heavy peace positions
have the safer King and things will work
out in your favor okay curling up into a
ball here musad just protecting
everything but won't last for long Rook
A7 what is the killer blow after Queen
takes Pawn on B6 there must be one there
just Rook G7 and the other Rook comes to
D7 oh look at a little dirty move there
she's just resigning oh but that real
coming to d8 would be game over after
that trade angelsard in big trouble here
we've had three decisive games and this
looks like it's going to be the fourth
decisive game and with that one massive
upset Jordan ran Forest taking his game
against so much action with four besides
the results David take us through the
big moment well I want to highlight the
one from Jordan van Forrest where he
came up with a really inspired really
instructive Queen sacrifice it was here
the black queen was attacked the black
Rook attacked as well and he decided
it's time to ditch the queen after
taking this taking this Knight first of
all Queen takes Queen he actually
ignored the White Queen he simply
captured and if we fast forward all of
the black pieces came together they
dominated the White Queen and in this
final position white resigned about to
get checkmated after Pawn to F5 disaster
start for your current Nakamura
what a big win that is with the black
pieces quite a start for Jordan run for
us let's take a result let's take a look
at our results going into round two of
division one first match and we see the
big big upset there Jordan winning his
games on the other three boards it was
the favorite who took the point with
Fabi defeating not a backup disaster of
a great attack by the heavy pieces takes
down Jules moussard and alireza ferruja
also made it look easy against Dimitri
colas it's been an exciting game and
this is what we predicted right with
this playing field it's gonna be intense
just action and more of that continues
after this twitch break
foreign
[Music]
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
at Magnus Academy we've taught chess to
a hundred thousand kids with Summer
around the corner we're gearing up for
camps
at online chess camps kids learn about
Chess in a safe fun environment from a
team of All-Star coaches
kids are grouped by skill level from
beginners up to national champions there
are never more than eight kids per coach
so every child gets plenty of attention
you might even get the chance to meet
Magnus and ask him a question or
challenge him to a game
each week has a different theme like
opening traps learning from your losses
or Magnus Carlson's best games
sign up by May 31st to get a 30 discount
join the 100
000 Kids and Counting that have learned
chess with Magnus chess Academy
foreign
we've witnessed moments that will last
forever
records and trophies first and only
game-changing Innovations from the
heroes we admire to the joy of watching
them play our history defines us
inspires us and pushes us into the
future
celebrating 75 years of changing the
game
Puma forever faster
a limited job of the MCs it's live on
Puma make sure to get your hands on them
they are the coolest chess shoes and of
course we are super excited about this
launch and about the chess get cup and
we've got a very special guest joining
us to talk more about chess game the
leading platform for kids to play chess
and to learn we've got my client with us
Mike welcome firstly where are you
joining us from what's going on there
experience
hey Tanya really apologize for my
connection but joining to you from uh
Madagascar the sun goes down very early
here
I think we are having some issues with
the sound that we will try to get Mike
back on as we fix those technical issues
and hear more from him on the chess gate
but for now Mike we'll try to have you
back on but for now let's just quickly
talk about the action that we just saw
Jordan van Forest that's got to be the
game of the round incredible I mean I'm
not gonna lie well I mean I don't think
anybody expected that result Hikaru with
the white pieces and he plays solidly he
almost never loses when he plays one
night F3 he was just trying to start off
solid Jordan with that Queen sack and
then the nerves of Steel it was
topsy-turvy it wasn't easy Tanya but he
gets the job done in the end huge game
one but that's just the tip of the
iceberg when you're playing Nakamura you
got three more games and Audi car is
gonna be mad Jordan's got to be feeling
the pressure the only thing worse than
playing Hikaru is playing an angry
Hikaru jam oh absolutely of course right
now I mean they call it him Michael
Jordan van Forest okay right but at the
same time when you have a angry Hikaru
like the Hulk like you don't like me
when I'm angry and that's just what
exactly we got to see from me Carl three
more games he's about to swing so Jordan
Jordan needs to be very very uh ready
for this next one for sure
and the other favorites did make it look
easy and I have to ask you David what
are The Underdogs well at least the ones
on the paper what do they need to do to
strike back well actually it's different
stories for some of those uh players
Jordan the underdog he's in the lead now
Dimitri colors the underdog he might
have lost the first game but he was in
control he was winning against vergia so
he just needs to do more of the same but
maybe with a bit more of a killer touch
a bit more confidence in closing the
game out for shimadov and uh Jewel musad
it's more difficult they need something
different they need to maybe attack if
they can in these uh next games
a vague round two coming up and we are
talking about the chess kid cup the
action is on now remember every Grand
Master was once a chess kid and as we
celebrate the big games the big action
that we're seeing we're also celebrating
with the chess cake cup the big talents
across the world and we had the
opportunity to meet one such talent
shreyas Royale take a look
I think when I was five six years old I
said I want to be a Grandmaster
[Music]
getting the title uh The Grandmaster
title but also being the youngest to do
it in the UK that was a huge goal uh it
drove me throughout my entire entire
childhood it was all I could think about
at times
[Music]
my friends they would be out playing
football out you know hanging together
and I would just be at home studying
chess playing chess whenever I could and
it was all with that one specific title
in mind so when I got it it was just I
mean the feeling was incredible I yeah I
ran back from the tournament Hall to
meet my mum she was crying with joy it
was uh yeah it was amazing I felt that I
had kind of paid some of what my parents
had sacrificed bringing me around the
world around the country every weekend
the record has been mined for 16 years
but I'm about to lose it
how are you nice to meet you
I'm currently thinking about The
Grandmaster record uh which Connie
stands I think at 16 years and one month
old by the man who's sitting right
opposite me I would be the youngest
English Grandmaster if I were to get the
title before then and I'm currently 14
years old so I think I have pretty high
chances I could try to get it this year
I don't know how many records I've held
but this would be probably my biggest
one so far
I got into chess through my father at
the age of six he taught me the basic
news and then I went to my local primary
school and they had a chess club there I
guess my first major achievement was
when I was seven years old I was feeling
very happy
um I felt I was good at something
and I was better than a lot of other
people
Justice's chess career was starting out
his future life situation became
uncertain shrez was essentially
Britain's chess hope and his father was
here on a work visa that work visa was
running out and essentially he was going
to be deported the people in the country
the English Chess Federation they didn't
exactly want to lose me I was also you
know really used to England I liked
being here I had a lot of friends I also
wanted to stay and I guess English Chess
Federation and my family and some more
important people also fought for my case
we launched a PR campaign to try and
keep trailers in the country which
gained an enormous amount of traction in
the end we got an unexpected call from
the home office saying that our Visa has
been extended feel pretty good I even
got the British passport so whenever I
traveled to tournaments I can use the
British passport and skip the long lines
recently shreyas Royal started working
as an ambassador for chess kid this
tournament sponsor helping others learn
the game
I'm really happy to be working with
chess kid to help get more players in
the UK playing chess and do some shows
with them and I play every week on chess
kid for against some of the players on
the side let's do this okay three two
one
[Applause]
behind my back no
nervous
okay
38 seconds okay but I have to mention
there was one rule that you did not
follow no we're supposed to take one
piece at a time
three two one go
oh 46 seconds uh but I was a bit I was a
bit naughty the way I did it well done
so David how would you feel about losing
the record uh it's about time it's been
too long I've held on to it too long so
I'm glad that someone is about to take
it we have a bunch of young teenagers
now who are breaking through and if I
could be the wise old man kind of
supporting them helping them along then
I'll Embrace that role I want to be a
top class Grandmaster hopefully 27 50ish
and that's that's pretty much my main
goal I have a feeling we'll see him in
the top hundred of the world within a
few years and from there it's up to him
whether he can hit the next level if he
really dedicates himself to chess
14 year old International Master SRI Ash
Royale from England with a big bright
future ahead of him and right now it is
Hikaru Nakamura who is looking for that
big bright future as he is playing with
the black pieces against Jordan he's
playing catch-up not something that
Hikaru is used to Jordan gets the white
pieces what's going to be his approach
Jim will Jordan try to play solid or are
you expecting him
to go for it with white well he's very
creative so I think he's just going to
play his game I think it's best to play
what you know best don't play anything
crazy you don't play anything weird
right just play what you know and of
course crazy and weird is actually how
he plays but of course just play what
you know here we got a modern whoa
modern typical Hikaru I mean he's been
playing this opening since the Civil War
era he knows the ins and outs of the
modern and he plays this when he needs
that win on Demand with black so this
isn't tilt this is standard Hikaru fair
and uh even a lot of top Grandmasters
David they don't exactly review the
modern that's not on the top list of
openings that you're reviewing so Hikaru
I mean he wants to get Jordan out of
theory but Jordan as I like to say when
I'm tilted he knows everything he sees
everything you're right Dania confession
time I've never studied this position
that's only move forward but Jordan's on
his own and well at least if he's not in
the zone he will be forced to answer
some very difficult questions it's up to
him now how to develop and no opening
theory in this one you guys kind of
highlighted that as one of Jordan's
strengths before the game before this
match and while provocative played by
Nakamura I've got to say pushing pawns
on both sides of the board and
neglecting development slightly that's
four pawn moves out of the first five
moves but is that exactly what you
expect from Hikaru when he needs to win
to level the match really enough to see
this uh modern opening the way he's
playing it too as well you you actually
sometimes can get worse positions as
white by making natural moves so like
Knight F3 or even playing F4 Knight E2
like that's probably what I would go for
F4 maybe 92 there just to get some space
in the center but lots of times you can
just find yourself being in a worse
position after making natural moves
against the matter usually because of
the pawn breaks and the flexibility and
the options that it gives you the car
has a lot of options in this position
wow and another pawn move five out of
six now
I wonder how many more porn moves he'll
push before he decides to develop or
Castle is kick don't try this at home
kids
Tanya but it was that guy Fabiana
karawana can we get some famous players
in here enough for the Obscure amateurs
wow Savvy we're the first round win
starts with the black pieces some crazy
openings on the Hikaru board but this
one starts more saying the knights are
developed so the more pieces coming out
on the board and we see perhaps in
English or is it going to be D4
yeah uh ahead of this tournament so I
did a bit of research for Shimano for
similar ages I played him a few times
when we were young but in recent years
less familiar with his games perhaps he
does tend to open games in this way
tends to be something a bit offbeat just
something a bit quiet risk-free with
white but now look looking off to the
side there shimanov he's just picking
what to play he goes for the fiancato
very logical stuff and I don't think
it's his style shimanov to kind of burn
its bridges and go all out attack from
move one despite the fact he's one point
down in this match still a long way to
go so sticking to his normal openings
and he's fighting two enemies right the
first is that he actually has a game to
play the second is that he had that
great chance apparently it was something
like minus two out of the opening in the
previous game we've all been there
during an over the board game you've got
a position in front of you all you're
thinking about is that other position
where you could have made that move
could have been 1-0 in your favor so
Shimano has to push all of that aside
right now he's got to decide whether he
plays D4 and transposes into a Catalan
or B3 and plays this reverse benoni
style which is what he's going to do
yeah from Miss Carolina has studied
everything in this type of position and
if he's in a solid mood it's going to be
very hard to Beat Bobby here so shimanov
is he going to trade off Pawns in the
center is he just going to develop his
dark Square Bishop fianca to that one
too lots of questions but early days and
very balanced very equal this type of
position usually if black knows what
they're doing that's
China being one of the best
[Music]
would you agree with that I think I saw
Hikaru mention something about Anish
also being topped there what do you
think Anish or Fabi I might have to go
with a
news theater I'm gonna have to go with a
nice just because of some Queen got some
courses out you know I'm Mr chessable
here I know all this stuff so he has a
lot of courses out a lot of course work
but I mean also Fabi did go to the world
championship based off crap even prepped
for a year to beat the Knight order from
nvl with the p sack wait a whole year
just to unleash this prep on him so
definitely gonna have to go with a nice
there but probably I think is a close
second here Bobby prep is prepped up and
look at this game here wow generally the
two best prepared players in the world
but right now it's also alireza ferruja
and we've got a
for this Farm that wow farooza just
playing the moment playing the match
he's one point up so why not just uh
choose a solid symmetrical opening like
the Petrov total symmetry almost right
now and it's going to be hard for
Dimitri to whip something up another
thing going for Theory and uh has
farusha done his homework this tends to
end up in very theoretical positions
that have been deeply studied so
interesting choice for that Daniel yeah
and the Petra are one of the oldest
openings in existence named after
Alexander Petrov who was the top Russian
player in the 1850s yesterday I was
actually reading uh the Russian chess
magazine the first ever Russian language
magazine it was edited by Alexander
Petrov and I was curious to see how he
referred to his own opening and he
referred to it as the Russian game then
later people started referring to it as
the Petrov Ali Reza doing what everybody
seems to be doing now that last game
David it was a hard break for Dimitri he
was up a rook then it was a dead drug
then he blundered one rook and then he
blundered the other one and now he's
down a point in the match
now chess can be brutal like that and
okay meanwhile some pressure it's all
revolving around this black knight in
the center the Knight on e4 and Dimitri
call us choosing a really creative way
to try and break down that Knight in the
middle I haven't seen this one before
I've got to admit guys never I mean he's
actually swinging I mean very very uh I
think impressive to say the least with
that Knight B4 move that he made was
really nice in the last game he was
winning there Knight G5 I have never
actually seen this move we always see C
takes D5 followed by a nice C3 or even
nice C3 immediately sometimes even
taking on e4 Knight G5 that one is is
going to make you think a little bit as
far Asia isn't a think tank here and
that is pretty nice loving this Knight
G5 move yeah very creative stuff and as
you pointed out we saw a similar motive
by Dimitri in that last game and of
course we've got action on our fourth
board as well with Jules musad currently
trailing not a back up to satrov Jewel
starts with the white pieces and once
again will another back take the
allureza path and decide to be solid
with black or will we see fireworks in
this one well French and James you
always call it out with the French that
it starts slow but it has all the
potential to be a blowout absolutely of
course I mean hey uh the French defense
is very solid of course you have the
bishop really the only problem they have
with the French is the bishop on C8 but
that doesn't mean that the position
isn't going to get aggressive and crazy
these positions get very razor sharp
from both sides here as we saw at that
uh Fabi game of course definitely a
chaminoff had some chances there but
probably was just able to to win that
game there it happens so let's see where
he goes here with Bishop B4 win our very
very uh sharp stuff here too as well
yeah not solid either
I've got say I do sator of playing the
French opening against the French
Champion that is brave stuff wow I would
not have predicted this beforehand and I
don't think jealous would have done
either no this is a ball Choice by Notre
back but if you don't know this line the
winower becomes the lose hour
you're all already revealing his
intentions he doesn't play E4 E5 which
is by far the most popular move but one
of the hard things about playing the
French that they're all these tricky
Sidelines and one of them is in fact
Knight G1 E2 usually followed up by A3
and either to cling to the pawn you have
to give up the bishop pair and leave
yourself with that bad candy Bishop on
C8 or if you play Bishop to A5 white
could chase that Bishop away from its
pinning square and then recapture on e4
yeah well do you think we'll see Abdu
Satora from my experience at least tends
to love his Bishops a bit of a bishop
fiend so I think he'll be reluctant to
uh capture this Knight right now uh
often black gives back the pawn if
possible just to get developed okay he
does take the Knight still one of the
main lines uh the Knight comes out to C6
attacking whites Pawn on D4 still
logical stuff still well known Theory
here and uh Jewel I'm expecting him to
either push that pawn forward or defend
it right now
lots of choice but uh still early days
in all of these games that we've seen so
far do we think some of the underdogs
are going to bounce back
that's exactly what they're looking for
currently one of them Jules musad he
starts with the white pieces will he
develop that Bishop to B5 Bishop to E3
but he says he's going all out strikes
in the center offers a queen trade but
if black does expect except that the
Knight jumps to the center of the board
puts pressure on the C7 Pawn we're
seeing moves being bits that and Jules
has managed to recapture the E4 Pawn
players are in familiar territory right
now we will take this moment while this
one heats up to jump over to the big
game between Hikaru Nakamura and Jordan
van Forest Jordan the player who scored
the first big upset and we've got
another crazy position out of the
opening wow another crazy position it
took me a moment there to uh find my
bearings looks like white has stacked up
his Bishops in the center uh Hikaru has
lost a bit of time with his Queen the
last move has been retreating the queen
back to her starting square and I've got
to say I'm loving White's position here
just feels like more space easier
quicker development what is that black
knight doing blacks pawns on the queen
side vulnerable potentially uh it's
possible to attack those later Hikaru is
setting up a threat meanwhile
threatening to take the White Knight the
white dark Square Bishop would be
vulnerable in the center but a very
loose play from Nakamura it feels like
he's really taking huge chances in his
in his bid to strike back so you get
some rescue this is reminiscing a little
bit of cgc Chess Global Championship
with Wesley so actually beating Hikaru
when it came to a a modern it was really
a crush there was pretty tough hard to
see there but here I mean it's
definitely similar I think in those
aspects that white just has the
development we got the pieces out we're
for Choice here we have a nice center
pieces look good right everything
principled is very nice for white here
but of course black still give me a haze
it's it's solid like I don't have any
real weaknesses really I mean I can't
Castle I can play E6 at some point
develop my knight right and of course
the engine oh hold on E6 there we go
there we go
Michael Jordan red Forest it ain't game
seven but he's playing like it's a game
seven it's the forest fire forest fire
from Jordan and uh wow this tactics
alarm Bells must have been ringing as
soon as Hikaru decided to delay the
castling as king and let's talk through
this variation sacrifice but uh only
temporarily uh is he gonna survive the
next few moves is this the big question
right now of course Bishop takes Knight
is possible Bishop takes Bishop there is
a threat against blacks on Defender
bishop and uh if we take this one down
here I think simply Point export is mine
this is terrible because if the king
takes the plan it steps onto the Mind
Square you can take the bishop with
check that's all she wrote If the King
goes the other way King D7 then you
could just play down a bishop Queen
takes half three look at that King look
at that point of seven David Bishop
takes D4 Rook ad1 at a minimum I mean
this is Cara will not touch this with a
10 10 foot pole now if you take the
bishop on D4 in the initial position
then white can just be calm and take
back on D4 and you even if black castles
white will take on F7 ruin black
structure you can Counter-Strike with C4
I mean Rook can come to D1 Jordan he
senses the moment right he senses that
this is his moment if he plays a couple
more accurate moves he can go up 2-0
that would be crazy Hikaru has played F6
David now Knight H4 has to be considered
you know strike while the iron is hot
yeah it looks really scary here the
black king is going to be vulnerable no
matter where it ends up another move
that you mentioned earlier Daniel just
bring the Rook across yeah Mr eye up
this black queen there are some tricks
here just to show one final one Bishop
takes Knight does not win a piece for
black because after Queen takes Bishop
this queen is loose and you can jump out
the way Discovery tactic with a check
gain some time next move the queen is
captured the queen Falls and with it
black would lose the game looking
beautiful for Jordan and just the fact
that this Pawn is landed on E6 is a huge
thorn in the black side how is this
knight ever going to develop
absolutely Michael Jordan Ben Forrest
right now the man is playing very strong
that was sick E6 and then now the pawn
is stuck on E6 he played Bishop before
maybe try to trade the only one of the
only pieces that can uh get rid of that
pawn of course is the bishop and maybe
the queen that can maybe slide over C8
to take the pawn on E6 so he says oh
let's get rid of that Bishop there open
up the file a little bit put a rook on
D1 Pawn on F6 like oh my goodness this
is really gross I mean but of course
there is chess left you do have to
convert what you have here or at least
try to against a very resourceful player
like Hikaru here so it is a task but at
the same time he is definitely for
choice in this game
I'm loving what Jordan is doing and he
again keeps the clock Advantage as well
he's up by almost four minutes on the
clock again something we're not used to
seeing with Hikaru down on the clock big
pressure on the position you can tell
just looking at Hikaru he's not loving
the way this match has gone it's not
something that he expected this last
move Bishop B4 if black was to capture
that E6 Pawn white is threatening to
either take on G6 or C6 perhaps you want
to take on G6 destroy that King Side
Pawn structure and pick up that Bishop
on E6 you're not letting that black king
castle that king is not going anywhere
is Hikaru in big trouble in this one
he's in huge trouble I mean his back is
against the wall obviously if he loses
the second one the match isn't over and
he very well could win two games in a
rotor Force Armageddon but that would be
walking you know a tightrope with tight
ropes four minutes down on the clock I
mean this is Unthinkable right now
Bishop E4 maybe not the best move Tanya
but Jordan from a position of strength
he's keeping his Advantage man oh man
man this is crazy
practical decision there you want to get
the Rooks to those Central files Bishop
before and we see Hikaru Nakamura is
going into a think in this critical
moment he really needs to bring out
those defenses and we will take this
moment to check in with ginger TM
Simon's with us in our Corner Studio
Simon what's the big update
yeah well hi there some great games
going on I mean I don't think anyone
expected uh this game this match between
Hikaru and Jordans go this way so we
will keep a close eye on that but going
to division two and remember the person
who wins division two gets into division
one we were following the match between
um
I have to get that right and fedexv and
so far mama jarov has won the first game
with black but then federusev won the
second game with black so all black
sides black pieces are winning that so
far which is a bit of a surprise and the
other match we're looking at in division
three uh was between Andrew tang and his
young Prodigy of opponent Vincent Kmart
and Vincent Kmart just won the second
round there to go uh one game up so
there's a lot to play for lots of stuff
going on lots of excitement and they're
all trying to move up their divisions
and get into the the big boy Division
and uh to maybe face the likes of uh
Hikaru amazing so much I action and
decisive games in division two entry
inside before we let you go I have to
ask you about what we're seeing on the
board can he car Omega come back in this
match what's your prediction
well if anyone can make a comeback it's
clearly Hikaru he's just so slippery
isn't he like a slippery eel he's very
hard to track down and actually kill but
I I'm just really impressed with the way
that Jordan is playing I mean Jordan so
far is playing fantastic chess and he's
kind of out calculating Hikaru and
that's something which uh you don't
really you don't really see or hear of
so all credit to Jordan at this moment
in time
some amazing play there by Jordan thanks
so much for those updates I mean we will
check in with you in some moments but
David we've got action a few more moves
have been made and at least the eval bar
confirms that Jordan keeps up the
Precision yeah the eval bar sometimes we
don't trust it sometimes we say okay
it's misleading in Practical terms it's
extremely difficult but here I think we
can trust the computer evaluation black
has finally castled but it's uh small
Solace here blacks Pieces Just Simply
trapped on the background dominated
white Rooks can gravitate towards the
center already you can start thinking of
picking off pawns really nice move there
from Jordan lining it up his white Rook
with the black queen and wow Nakamura
needs a miracle here he needs to somehow
get the Black Knight onto a more uh
active square but even that alone will
take several moves and it's a luxury he
won't have yeah yeah you can tell you
when I woke up and chose violence today
I mean this is the day that like you
know everybody's like oh your car is
going to crash him he car over this he
carried that which it is I mean of
course he has the accurate age but today
is not his day right now especially as
we might see an O2 from Hikaru in the
first two of the chess cake Cup today
this is actually really bizarre but I
mean Jordan is very creative if it's
anybody that's very creative and to make
things and pose problems it's someone
like creative and strange type of Chess
creative we say
um like you're very very impressive and
yours has got to keep this momentum
going right not let it
to his head not get flustered by the
math situation currently and B4 on the
board you just compare white pieces to
Black species what is that night on ba
doing far from developing currently
Hikaru is playing without the Knight
without the Rook without the queen he's
shaking his head he trades that Bishop
on C4 the only active Bishop in Black's
position is now off the board and Hikaru
trying for some counter play Daniel on
the queen side yeah and Jordan he
oversalted it on the queen side I think
he overcooked it a little bit maybe
should have brought the other Rook to D1
I was gonna say hikaru's flight to D7
International Airport has been canceled
just like my flight from Newark to Oslo
thanks SAS but you can go through A6
right you can fly through a different
route and Jordan is trying to prevent
that his last move Rook V1 at x-rays the
queen so if you play Knight A6 here
white will take on A5 and say thank you
for the pawn but Hikaru can avoid that
he can play A4 to close down the queen
side or he can take on B4 so the eval
bar dropping a little bit but David I
think you'll agree with this important
not to overstate it very much still in
control of the game is Jordan Bend
Forest Queen A6 can be considered Hikaru
has to Slither around on the sides but
also keep an eye on that E7 Pawn which
is under Fire as well yeah so many
questions uh to Onset for Hikaru like
you say Daniel one move if you could get
it for free maybe re-route the Knight
either capture this bishop or bring it
round uh towards the center then you cut
kind of at least some argument for uh
decent foundations of a position a
playable position but right now it's far
far from playable still you have to
decide what to do and uh I'm struggling
here after A5 Rook B1 what do you
I mean I don't want to open this I don't
really want to allow the white rook in
even if you can try and exchange Queens
it feels like at the very minimum you
will lose this Pawn at the very end
James I'm struggling I've got to say I
need help he currently needs help oh
yeah he definitely needs some help right
now 100 this is difficult here I mean
he's facing it I mean look at the time
too as well you rarely ever see Hikaru
down on time that was both games he's
been Town time by the way wow fancy move
there huh fancy Knight Ace I think well
Knight a61's Rook D7 that's his idea
something feels off about the way he's
playing looks like your car was close to
untangling he needs that one more
resource maybe Queen B5 or queen A6
maybe give up the seven Pawn because
then you'll be able to go rookie eight
in some circumstances and win the pawn
back but four and a half minutes now for
Nakamura and one more mistake he loses
the game regardless of what the evil Bar
says yeah and maybe we can ask the
computer's help here how many moves does
Hikaru have to unravel okay one move
minimizes the damage everything else
looks like a huge Advantage for white
that was it found it rookie found it
great move this move at first I was
reluctant I thought oh wow I could plant
a rook on D7 with the idea that if you
take it this is just a discover check
and I win the black Rook but of course
uh black will not get tempted by the
material here and we'll simply trade the
Queens off
suddenly Signs of Life for Hikaru
Nakamura
very sourceful as we say as always if
anyone can do it it is Hikaru in these
type of positions he found rookie eight
very tough move not the hardest to find
because you do understand okay e7's
hanging we do want to defend it but the
move water really matters here 96 was
something you really wanted to play but
rookie 8 of course defends E7 Rook D7 is
going to be answered with Queen to B5
here uh Hikaru shakes his head after the
rookie eight move but he always shakes
his head it was the best move on the
board still shaking and say oh I had
this no you actually didn't but rookie 8
was the best move here and he's trying
to untangle here but he is still
downtime and he does have an uphill task
to try to get the rest of these pieces
out and develop and hopefully have some
chances for uh some life I don't think
anyone's surprised when he got or not
coming around finds the only good move
in the position he is known for his
resistance and resourcefulness it is an
exciting game but the other action that
has got my eye David ferrugia versus
Dimitri look at that eval bar it says
that firuza is on the way to win to get
his second win in that match and we're
going to take this moment to jump over
and get an update on that one let's try
and pull that up David what's going on
there so as the evaluation Bar says
farrugia is winning however it is level
material and if he doesn't seize this
moment then call US is right back in the
game so just as we wait for that board
uh to come up yeah alvareza farooja has
a chance to land almost a knockout blow
in their match that he needs to be
accurate he needs to calculate well I'm
still not writing it off that game
despite what the computer says and uh
here we see it level material queen of
Knight versus queen of Bishop is uh the
imbalance right now both sides have
Rooks Pawns of course but uh killer blue
we need to find it
what can ferrugia play level time here
about seven minutes each so it will be
well worth the investment if feroza
spends two or three of those valuable
minutes and finds a way to attack queen
of Knight the ideal attacking combo here
great Duo when they can face off against
alone King but I don't see it it's not
easy gotta say
I think I might be on to something so if
you go Knight F4 which is begging to be
played that's not what alirez is
thinking about but after G3
there might be some idea related to
Queen dropping back on the H file when
H6 right G takes F4 Queen H5 doesn't
matter then Queen H3 check King G1 and I
think the Rook lift might decide the
game rookie 6 threatens both the
Checkmate on G6 as well as Rook H6 which
sets up further made threats on H1 and
maybe H2 so this path is indeed narrow
but
I feel like alireza's got the time to
find it that's very nasty in fact I was
trying to figure out what happens after
King G1 I was like yeah you sacked the
piece obviously within King G1 Rook E6
was the move that you have to spot there
and that's a hard one not the hardest to
find but you have to see it in
calculation before you actually do this
move oh he's being the first right now
James do you think he's gonna find this
Beast side yeah he probably found it now
he probably found it now big moment that
G3 on the board will alireza sacrifice
the night with this line that David
shows with the queen coming into the
attack followed by The Rook left queen
H5 a big move that could begin whoa
Gucci resin I was gonna say this is very
tempting as well because now you're
hitting the queen hitting the pawn it's
easy to get tempted when you have such
an attractive move the other move was an
instant kill however and uh now maybe
white has chances of fighting back maybe
you can use the fact that this black
Rook is slightly loose so you can
perhaps play okay he's beat me to it
Queen A3 on the board and now you do not
have time to take this Pawn because
after Knight takes a queen capture you
have been deflected away and this Rook
will hang chance missed and White's back
in the game not only that but the Knight
only two is stranded James rookie one is
a huge threat this isn't just black
having all the fun White's having some
fun too now isn't he absolutely of
course as we know we like tactics here
tactinos for breakfast lunch and dinner
after an 82 we do have a rookie one a
nice looking trap E7 you have to be very
accurate here what do you even do maybe
like a rook E6 is that possible Ricky
one and then we could take on G3 it's
possible maybe we just move the Rook up
one and then yeah that's probably the
move here
Ricky rookie six is fine just so maybe
go F4 first but then Queen G4 yeah still
some we got some work to do definitely
have some work to do with the uh White
pieces yeah both sides uh have work to
do here and very much in the balance
after a huge missed opportunity for
furusia
what a big mess it could have
potentially been game over had alireza
found that attacking idea with the queen
transfer to the H5 giving up a piece but
Falling for Temptation their Knight E2
looks so strong but now he goes into a
thing realizing that it's not as easy
and great call there by James rookie six
on the board it looks like Dimitri
kolars he's on his way to make a
comeback in this position and of course
the big question also is can Hikaru make
a comeback in his position we're going
to take this moment to jump straight
back to the action with Hikaru against
Jordan Hikaru currently down a point and
it looks like he's managed to salvage
the opening disaster that this was
uh he's back in the game that black
knight still on the edge of the board
but it can trade itself off for White's
Bishop at will the whole Queen cider
disappeared all of the pawns now on one
side of the board that means that uh at
least there's less danger for Hikaru and
uh how is white ever going to break
through towards that black king unclear
so okay still in the balance this one
anything could still happen what do we
think of the chances I think this is
what he wanted I think uh from a mindset
psychology standpoint he car was feeling
much better you can even see like he
feels better usually you see this face
when he's like focused in title Tuesdays
he feels a lot better about the position
right now also I think the knight's
gonna reroute to C6 maybe more
centralized of the night there after he
removed the queen here
um it's pretty good I think uh he feels
much better but I still actually like
white here we got the pawn on E6 H5 the
the uh the like margin of error here is
very very small you have to be careful
still with black but definitely he's
feeling better than playing pawns all on
the same side the same amount of
material here too as well definitely
some errors there from Jordan but he is
up time and it is up to Hikaru to make
you know some things happen out of this
position especially with this Pawn on E6
still white is definitely the one I
would like to have here yeah I was going
to say Jordan in the first game
sacrifices Queen could he have left the
queen on that square such a sacrifice it
again but here's the point up in the
match he doesn't want risk so the Queens
have come off but uh this end game
Hikaru tends to be so good at wriggling
around here and that white E6 Pawn I do
fear for Jordan if Hikaru does uh start
attacking it maybe long term it might
drop off a bit of a weakness do you
think Daniel I think you already needs
to try to bail out Play Bishop A3 and
Hikaru could force the draw there with
Knight A6 to C7 and the e-pawn is traded
for Black's epon uh but Man compared to
what this was about 15 moves ago you
feel like you're winning if you're Cairo
now you have to put things in
perspective if you're Jordan okay it's a
draw not the end of the world I think he
car was playing for a win because Knight
C7 David that was a first draw I think
Rook C3 signals that Hikaru actually
feels that he can pull this out there
might be some tactics here with Bishop
takes C7 but they have to be calculated
and White's Bishop
it's not very comfortable you don't want
to go back to C1 you want to keep
contact with that E7 Pawn so maybe the
way to do it is to swing your Rook to A5
but suddenly Jordan's the one who's got
to make some decisions here yeah big
decision you can defend it as you say it
down yet but then another attack this
time against your e-pawn how do you
control this again do you want to put
your piece of bad squares do you want to
kind of tie down your own Rook maybe you
need to at some point I think the dream
now for Jordan is actually to get these
guys traded off the board and make that
draw as you say I'm not sure how you
achieve this okay Rook A7 played on the
last turn very very sensible I think
there from Jordan and the idea of course
after Knight takes you can even capture
with the Rook everything off the board
and three versus three in terms of Pawns
on the same side this will fizzle out to
a draw
you're done cutting it fine there Hikaru
still feeling ambitious he does not want
to bail out though he does not want to
simplify down maybe there's no rush yet
maybe it's black you can play a move or
two uh kind of weight removal to before
capturing on E6 but either way feels
like equality now
100 percent of me very impressive from
Hikaru here of course uh Jordan was uh
it's difficult you know you did have a
great position early on I mean almost
winning I think the eval bar was almost
like plus three at some point but I mean
having this position now it is kind of
like you with why you like oh man it
hurts it sucks but hey you up in the
match if it's a draw right you didn't
just say it is what it is it's a drawing
we try to take our chances with the
black pieces Bishop f8 he literally
doesn't care literally doesn't care he
just wants to go for the win at all
costs done there's two people who would
go for the win in that position Magnus
Carlson is one or Nakamura is the other
everybody else so thank God I made a
draw I'll take that E6 Pawn you know
faster than uh I'll shake magnus's hand
if he offers me a draw but Hikaru no
he's feeling he's feeling it he's down
50 seconds on the clock but it's all
about the trend of the game David that
fact that Jordan is winning he knows it
right he's not blind to that fact and
that might be hampering him from playing
this objectively but Jordan he is
staying afloat he's keeping his
composure and I love what he's doing
here to try to force those pawns off the
board any cars saying not a yes
wow that black knight is feeling so
uncomfortable right now but it is the
glue holding together Black's position
and yeah I think that's what separates
the current Nakamura Magnus costume from
the rest of us I'm Immortals no fear
willing to take chances and momentum
definitely on black side okay Jordan
pushing his Pawn forward
are you like that and I don't like it at
the same time it feels like uh he's
playing for the attack still when maybe
uh there was something a bit more
forcing for Jordan Hikaru drops his back
controlling the white knight from
jumping forward anywhere watch out for
that black king to start advancing as
well still Jordan's a bit stuck if any
of his pieces move those the that white
E6 Port will fall off the board and it
could well come down to a bullet game
now and we know how dangerous Hikaru is
there
that last Bond sacrifice with H5 if it
would have been captured white would
have jumped with the Knight forward
found its way to F5 but Rook C4 nice
move by Hikaru Nakamura taking control
of the fourth rank making sure that
white knight doesn't indeed find itself
on the F5 Square notice how the move G3
actually wanted to get that knight from
H4 now all the way to F5 so both players
trying to get their initiative in the
position the one thing I don't like in
Black's position is that Bishop on f8
can we just talk about that Bishop what
is it doing there
so it might be a bad Bishop but it has a
purpose now Hikaru as you're mentioning
senses the momentum for the first time
in this match he's the one who's up on
the clock by 20 seconds he's going to
try to put pressure more on that time
advantage and now we see the move Bishop
to B2 some pins on those diagonals
potential Knight jumps to G5 can this
ambitious play by Hikaru backfire
absolutely Jordan's went great right now
Bishop B2 using tactics I mean he car
was walking on hot coals were just so
used to him doing it successfully that
sometimes we forget how dangerous the
strategy is David yeah completely agree
and actually we can just show that
moment you mentioned the tactics there
Dania uh if black had got greedy Knight
takes porn it looks like the white
Bishop has departed from uh its threat
against E7 then suddenly Rook takes Pawn
would be a killer blow you give up one
Rook but you get two pieces in return
next move this Knight will drop off when
black replies to the check Hikaru was
forced to start bringing his King to the
edge of the board he did Force this
exchange but uh now okay developments
and if we catch up with the current
position it is certainly Hikaru who's
trying to change things he's trying to
wiggle around with his King and uh
remove this Pawn from the board I said
don't lead with your king from the front
earlier but now Queens are off the board
the black king relatively safe and
Jordan is a bit stuck the white Rooks
look nice and pretty but they aren't
doing too much and the rest of your
pieces also lacking a purpose so okay
white just wait eating hanging around
kanhikaru do the business and keep
improving the clock time suddenly all in
Black's favor yeah
there's going to be a grind by the two
players let's take this moment to jump
to all the excitement that's happening
on the Dimitri versus
the Dimitri is on the brink of Victory
making his comeback he's up a piece and
he won that night only two that night
that jumped to E2 incorrectly it's gone
wow this is the second time we should
mention today that colors has been up a
piece in the first game he was up a
piece against veruga he went down he
crashed to defeat but surely this one
looks like a safe version everything's
protected for white simply a bishop for
two pawns up and those black pawns are
not making a great impression this one
must be a victory for white absolutely
it's looking very clean you can do
something of course even as simple as
Queen A7 I mean even here Queen A7 and
go back to D4 like what do you do what
do you have what are you threading I
don't really see it we take A7 we come
back we go Queen D4 we try to trade the
pieces off the rule is trade when you're
up now when you're down everything's
defended it's a very nice game here it's
going to take a lot or a blunder like
what happened in last game Queen D4 hey
however you want to do it we're
definitely winning here we're up a piece
he's trying to convert yeah you can take
this the C4 Port now I think pretty
safely just uh get greedy why not
minimal threats the only potential
Hazard is uh the black queen coming
across but wow there we go that's nice
really nice geometry just blocking off
the black Queen's attempted infiltration
there and again Cruiser has to run away
from that trade Bishop down and no
threats anymore for black you can just
slowly untangle this one I think it's a
matter of time Dimitri as well handling
the clock so well three minutes left and
it's just a matter of technique as they
say
yeah anything else to add if it was like
a win for white it's inevitable here
just a matter of time
is up a whole piece it looks like he's
going to be taking this point but of
course the action on the Hikaru board
that end game was anyone's game with
both people with both players pushing
for a win there we also see Fabiano
caruana shemanov has ended in a draw a
while as well as with Jules Musa drawing
his game against another back up to such
Rob this is where the action is we can
call this one out as Dimitri taking this
point guys what do you say should we
switch to the Hikaru board absolutely
let's switch borrowing a big blunder
this one is a win for white all right
let's bring up the board Hikaru Nakamura
will he be able to come back in this
round two that pawn on E6 which was such
a big strength for Jordan has turned to
be the big weakness in this end game he
continues to push for it now that dark
Squad Bishop is finding its activity I
think yagar is going to win this game
now he's flat out better I mean he's
dominating the night Jordan with 10
seconds Hikaru just doing Hikaru things
and F3 David I can see your expression
of disgust Jordan now is the one Walking
the Tightrope probably still a draw
objectively even if he loses that pawn
but you just know he car is going to
play that position for 700 moves yeah
what else to say it is going to be a
long grind Jordan also with under 10
seconds on the clock I don't like where
he's put his two white Rooks okay a pawn
has dropped he's begging for Bishop
versus knight trade now uh I was gonna
say earlier that black Bishop on f8 even
the worst Bishop is sometimes as good as
the best Knight and uh here it's
definitely a case of that black Bishop
having uh sprung to life and yorda's
just hopping around hoping now but the
pawns are coming soon that white king is
going to come under an attack oh my God
E4 bring that Bishop in goodbye end of
the game
C1 winning more material and Hikaru
Nakamura making it look easy in the end
game that was actually incredible play
by Hikaru that was literal Wizardry I
mean that was at some point a completely
winning position for Jordan he started
going a little bit wrong overcooking it
on the queen side there but to win that
end game you had a three on three where
Jordan was dominating and Hikaru putting
the finishing touches on that game but
at this point there's nothing to say
it's over yep simply those black pawns
are gonna match for it the white Knights
kind of hold things together much longer
Jordan's ready to get out of there just
playing on out of inertia but uh wow
heartbreaking this matches totally
turned if this game was a draw it
wouldn't have been the worst thing yeah
this one hurts this one definitely hurts
from Jordan that one definitely hurts
you have to it's even Hikaru says he has
a quote like hey when it comes to losses
you got to get over them very quickly
short-term memory loss because like this
one is gonna sting you knew you were
winning you were doing better you know
you were trying to clinch this match
here O2 two oh Hikaru here to lose this
one when you're winning especially with
the white pieces is definitely a tough
one
wins the second game what a phenomenal
game by him in a difficult position he
played masterfully in that end game this
is why he is one of the best defenders
in the world well this one as well we
see Dimitri is about to make his
comeback he's up a piece not even for a
pawn and I don't really see an attack
for black I don't see a way to create
counter play against White's King Rooks
are gonna come off the board is this
over it is and with that on that call we
see that the metricola scores a big win
with the white pieces leveling his match
against alireza ferrugia amazing amazing
chefs all around big moments to pick out
from and David what was the highlight
for you the Highlight Tanya has to be
Hikaru Nakamura coming back equalizing
the score in his game and it was such a
good practical decision uh earlier we
saw him just keep the game alive at any
moment he could have captured this Pawn
hoovered off all the pieces and it would
have been a draw but just slowly edging
forward pushing this Pawn bringing his
King around to try and Gobble up White's
Pawn just slow and steady nerves of
Steel and eventually he went on to win I
recommend everyone at home to go and
play through this end game in slow
motion there's a lot to learn
so much inspiration and to learn for all
the chess kids out there to not give up
we saw Hikaru with patients winning that
pawn what a phenomenal play in that end
game he levels the match let's take a
look at our score line going into the
third round of the quarterfinals we see
Hikaru Nakamura Strikes Back in round
two and not just him Dimitri collage
against jaliers affiruja also levels the
match meanwhile not a back up to satrov
and Fabiano caruana continue to keep
their lead a lot of action intense chess
is on and we will be back with more
Cascade action after the switch break
foreign
[Music]
tonight
of focus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space shifting your state with
every breath
find your air of clarity now
[Music]
this is your opportunity to get your
hands on the Magnus Carlsen Clyde chess
limited drop on a puma James my favorite
bit about the shoes needs to be those
kings on the laces oh I like those yeah
the King on the laces guys the shoes are
absolutely amazing I actually did a
thousand curls with them in the
beginning of the show so of course if
you do a thousand you'll start to feel
them but the shoes were very nice they
even have a chess piece right on the
tongue there it's amazing it's also on
the uh the lid there I mean it's
everywhere like the that's that's a very
cool shoe hopefully they got it in
different colors too we can get some
black ones some white ones some red ones
I'm gonna have to spin my whole check
there or chesscom thank you for spending
uh money to get these shoes for us those
are amazing great idea there are more
colors but right now it is the classic
black and white and you can get your
hands on on these uh shoes on Puma right
now and of course we also have a lot of
fun with the chess action that we're
seeing on day one of the chess kit cup
we've been seeing a lot of decisive
games some amazing matchups there and I
want to ask you David how difficult will
it be for Jordan to let go of what
happened in game two simply because he
was better out of the opening yeah we've
all been there when we've crashed to
defeat when we thought we had everything
under control and that is hard enough to
recover from to recover when you were
completely winning when you're already a
point up in the match when you saw the
Finishing Line in sight it's going to be
extremely difficult I'm not sure if
anyone is up to that task and uh Hikaru
he smells blood he's gonna be ready to
pounce and uh really kick the boot in
now so Hikaru big favorite yeah
some amazing play by Hikaru he bounces
straight back in round two winning a
difficult game with the white pieces and
of course the other impressive
performance was by Dmitry collage taking
his win against alireza ferrugia that
was some great chess Daniel
the tree showing incredible resolve
losing a heartbreaker in round one a
game that he never should have lost and
then on the edge of defeat in game two
alireza had that winning line we were
predicting that he would play it but
maybe some of that rust showing in
Dimitri not giving Reza a second chance
it's zero zero and if you're the lower
rated player Tanya you want this to go
to the Armageddon right because that
raises uh the likelihood of something
crazy happening not just the players the
fans and Asus commentators we want to
see those Army Gardens now the clocks
are ticking which means that the players
will have liftoff in just a few moments
our Focus will be on the Hikaru versus
Jordan matchup and guys I have to ask
you we've got to do a little prediction
here Hikaru will he try another London
after the disaster of game one no more
London systems please yeah unless this
is a joke
baby let's go but if it's that that's
what we're doing I think he's gonna play
E4
the guy who had enhance probably
thinking about what he needs to start
with but I would agree that it would be
an absolute shocker to see another
London it did not work out at all for
the American champion the five-time
speed chess champion Hikaru Nakamura in
game one Daniel they're predicting one
E4 it's also going to be interesting to
see what Jordan comes up with he is a
player who's known for his off-beat
opening ideas very unique preparation
one E4 but Daniel it's not the case he
starts with a refi structure wow that's
pretty uncommon from Macklemore who
likes to develop his Queen's Bishop
first when he plays Knight F3 he usually
follows it with B3 David here clearly
adhering to the same strategy trying to
avoid Theory and immediately settling
into a think after G6 which is a very
fashionable move yeah I've seen uh
Jordan employ this before and uh we
should also mention Jordan's air quality
not great adding perhaps to the fact
that things have been spiraling a bit
out of control over the last hour
against uh Nakamura and okay opening
wise he's got the center Nakamura needs
to fight against that often White NOW
strikes pushes oppon forward there we go
he's basically playing a king's Indian
defense Nakamura remember is one of the
the world's leading authorities on the
king's Indian
he's playing it with reverse colors
however white set up there and it has
allowed Jordan to Simply get Queens off
the board at this early stage Jordan it
not isn't necessarily his style he
doesn't really like getting Queens off
kind of playing end games it does favor
Nakamura but objectively I think a good
choice objectively this looks very
balanced to me James thoughts on this
disappointing to see the Queen's come
off it is and Kingsley and Emmy and even
me and Dania are Kings Indian like of
course we just love Kings and in defense
like it's very annoying when these
Queens come off like this you do have
your choices of C3 Knight A3 Rook D2 and
I think even Rook D3 our moves here in
Reverse yeah the C3 move which is the
standard but I mean it just gets boring
it's very boring and of course yeah okay
King's Indian you don't really want
those type of structures here but he was
kind of forced into it when he played
the E4 move he could have maybe went
Knight D2 first then try an E4 just to
mix it up a little bit but at the same
time here I mean Carl can play any
position this one is going to be a long
game for sure
Jordan with his expression
saying James he's not impressed
impressed Queen trade
in because all other pieces are still
there so there's still a lot to fight
for this is going to be a long grind
everything in control now the other
player who has been in control so far is
Fabiano caruana he does lead his match
against shimanov and they are ready to
start there round three Fabi at one and
a half with the white pieces he's got to
be feeling good what are we expecting
well maybe another French defense yeah
exactly right yeah you know Bobby
actually uh he says he always says like
you know I actually had time well cgc
when we were at cgg and me and Daniel
and uh actually I'm like yo what do you
like to you're playing E4 D4 like what
do you really like he's like yeah I'm
mostly E4 right so he's played a little
bit of everything I think E4 for sure he
loves his stuff even if you look at his
repertoire it's mostly E4 I'm 100 E4
here with Bobby
yeah
I mean it's so hard to say whether shimo
is going to repeat that French line
because Fabi wasn't born yesterday he's
not just gonna walk into that same
position either Fabi will deviate early
with Knight D2 instead of Knight C3 or
you use that break to look up the line
so shimanov is a Karo Khan player I
think from birth so he might resort to
what he feels more comfortable with a
lot of questions here we're about to
find out yeah and uh Fabiano with
slightly better air quality than we saw
from Jordan so will that help him uh we
know that players tend to play worse
towards the end of the day as he gets
later as the air quality in that room
gets uh worse open the window everyone
has to help we've seen it before on The
Talk plenty of times and we've also seen
this before uh the French defense and
Moment of Truth
a new one a new third move yeah with
Bishop before so it is a classic venovo
now Mainline stuff and Fabby knows a
thing or two here Bishop A5 though
slightly more red aren't you yeah that's
called The Armenian variation it's named
after a few uh OG's Raphael veganyan uh
symbol of Putin two a very strong
Armenian gems from the 90s who played
this line religiously it fell out of
fashion
um because of this move B2 B4 uh for
which for a while was considered the
refutation of the line but nowadays
white has other options I don't know how
the theory of this line has developed
shimanov adhering to the general
strategy right playing the French and
then playing something offbeat which he
has researched better than Fabi and
Fabby takes on C5 took a little bit of
time to remember his prep yep takes on
C5 this is uh also a move but perhaps
not uh too popular because white was
achieving a set of triple pawns there
and uh okay we are about to see farrugia
as well kick off at this game let me
strike back after defeat in the previous
one look at fuja in on the camera there
with his head on hands he is not pleased
with the way the match has gone so far
but it could have been a lot worse for
him Dimitri colors was also better in
game one he did strike back in game two
and we have seen fireworks in this match
so far we expect more of that now for
Fairuza with the white pieces and we've
got action on wow it is going to be
another Catalan structure
yeah another Catalan just as it was in
game one between these two where ferusia
did obtain an advantage but let it slip
later on and a bit of a roller coaster
game that one first this check very
trendy stuff one of the main lines of
the Catalan and frujo how would he block
this with his Knight or his Bishop
Bishop I think Bishop I think Knight
because it is my queen
it reminds me of that Meme uh when uh
it's like a picture of Hikaru Fabi and a
niche oh yeah and it's a famous one
right where everybody's mating
differently and Anisha is that
yeah what the smirk yeah I think wins
the bat locks with the bishop and uh the
game goes on no Queen blunders no King
moves it is just very standard Catalan
stuff this is uh standard fare often
black is very solid but white has more
control over the center at least for now
think get a suit version let's go let's
go I'm so hyped oh my goodness
can we get to CH4 in every single
opening now I love seeing H4 I don't
care what it is of course me being a Jar
Jar Binks London AKA Joe Bava London
expert right with another expert right
next to me we do love to see an h-pawn
push especially from the white side H4
Knight G5 sunlight G4 too if you're
gonna go H4 you might as well go
everything then Knight G5 and G4 and
just try to take his head off here oh my
God the to-do it seems like that one's
gonna be a hot middle game you got H4
and we love it we live as you say James
see more age for Action well currently
in nordeback Abdu satro of is leading
the match one and a half to half and we
see Jules Musa they are ready for
liftoff and again it comes down to their
opening approach we've got another Queen
spawn opening and is it going to be a
Queen's Gambit declined it looks that
way Tanya which variation is Musa gonna
choose okay uh now he's fighting in the
center this does tend to lead to very uh
kind of sterile positions if white isn't
in the mood for a fight the Berlin of
1d4 as they say semi-tarash here and
okay I've just a tour of chooses to keep
more tension in the center now play
transposes to the Queen's Gambit
accepted and uh often black will try to
expand on the queen side as quickly as
possible still very Mainline stuff I
know Musa has had this in this
repertoire for a long time from the
black side the Queen's cupboard accepted
and uh hey who will this suit at an
early stage I've just sort of it feels
like he's in the mood to fight all right
his first White game was very very
impressive and he took the lead he could
end it here and now if he wins
but uh yeah early days of course in this
game yeah very early days here I think
A6 move of course you this is just a
classic Theory here he wants he's trying
to figure out what he wants to do A4 you
can also just castle and allow B5 and
back to Bishop up but he really just
trying to figure out what he wants to do
here which is so you have many options
Daniel what would you what do you go for
here yeah I mean d takes C5 is also
possible I don't approve of that and A4
as you said of course the downside that
weakens the B4 Square uh but you don't
have to worry about B7 B5 so oftentimes
black plays B6 which is compromise I
mean still you need to eventually
develop your Bishop yeah and this is
still standard fare I think E5 here
uh is a move and you get a lot of draws
in this line David because there's a
very high chance that the center
basically liquidates and there you see
it yeah uh we will eventually reach a
symmetrical position white is likely to
win the earlier sacrifice to pawn back
but uh yeah as you say that Daniel
things do fizzle out slightly it's also
a direct transition to A variation of
the slav defense but black has this
extra move A6 and even without this move
A6 which surely helps black uh the
position there tends to be acceptable
for back so looks like moussard has got
out the opening in a solid state and uh
is after happy with that that's the
question he still needs to remember and
uh I don't think he'll want to risk too
much unless he really has to with white
and we are also getting a big update
that the third round game between Hikaru
Nakamura and Jordan van Forest after
that Queen trade has in fact ended in a
draw so it will go down to that fourth
and final rapid game will we have an
Armageddon that is the big question
we're seeing some traits on this one
there's action here Daniel whoa and
currently white is temporarily
sacrificed to peace this is all Theory
right if you're saying this for the
first time it may appear exciting just
like the Berlin with Queen D4 and queen
E4 and so we find out and this was
played by caboblanca 8 000 years ago and
it's been well known ever since now from
an untrained eye knight F3 check might
seem sensible to give away the Knight on
ruined white structure but then Black's
kinky gets stranded in the center so
probably more wise here to prioritize
the safety of your king castle give the
Knight back up and I mean again to my
untrained eye looks like wet is an
initiative but uh I think it's probably
objectively equal if black is careful
yeah I remember actually studying if not
this exact position at least the
position without the pulled on A6 and
the key to solve your problems as
moussard has just shown that get the
Queens off the board White Queen is
nicely centralized you're about to get
hit in the center anyway swap the
Queen's Force the Queens off and yes
white will regain the Knight but at the
very end you have a nice active bishop
and pawn structure almost symmetrical
with this game is likely to uh end in a
draw so great opening preparation for
massage but a decent result there for
abdusitor of inching him closer to match
victory yeah if this one ends in a draw
it means that Jewels will have to go all
out in that final round but he will get
the white pieces and that very well
could be his math strategy and joining
us in our studio once again is ginger
Jam Simon Williams with more math
strategy from division two and three
Simon what's up yeah hi there everyone
um well I heard someone shout H4 and I
thought I better better come in the
studio basically and uh we've got lots
of updates in division three and two and
I'm just going to bring you some uh some
of the matches that ended in division
two now one player you should really
keep an eye open for is Liam Lee he's a
fantastic player and he won his match uh
free nil which was a brilliant result
against baraf so he's through to the
next round we also have KIRO Alex senko
through he beat
um George Mayer and um lots of the other
matches still going on they're quite
close but those people are through and
the next person is through is ranook
sadwani a young Indian player and he won
his match uh against mamicon so uh those
players they can relax a little bit
they're they're through to the next
round and of course the winner of
division two gets to play against these
big guns here in division one and that's
where you want to be isn't it division
one inside layer that we have on our
screen not back up to such off he in
fact made his way into the Chaska cup
division one by winning division two of
the chatsworld master so for these
players sure the prize money that's cool
and all but this is the big ticket that
they're counting on yeah this is where
you want to be this is where all the
action is this is where you make your
name and this is where you can win well
even bigger bucks as well so uh it's a
great situation of being he's a
fantastic player anyway
um you know a young gun and he's just
going from strength to strength but
you've had some really exciting matches
haven't you this Hikaru match uh against
Jordan has to be the highlight of the
day and uh I have no idea what's going
to happen in the last game of that it's
going to be very exciting and because of
what you just mentioned I'm gonna put
you on a spot and ask you to make a
prediction here because we are going
into the final and the fourth rapid game
between Hikaru and Jordan the score is
level Psy are we gonna see an army
Garden in that one or will it be decided
in the rapid game
I think their momentum is now going with
Hikaru I mean Jordan had a chance to go
to nil up uh but I I do want to see an
Armageddon so uh even if I think Hikari
is probably going to win I'm going to
say Armageddon come on bring on some
Armageddon for us
I think we can all agree with that
sentiment thank you so much I mean for
all the updates and we will catch up
with you in some moments from now right
now it is back to division one action we
see a lot of Trades a level position in
this game the Hikaru game has ended
against Jordan and I want to take our
attention to the Fabiano board he is up
against shimanov shimanov also needs to
win a game to level that match and let's
bring up the Fabi board and get an
update on that one David
yep so uh we will get an update once we
jump in this game in front of us I'll do
the tour off against moosad looks very
balanced almost symmetrical look at the
Bishops just canceling each other out I
think uh not too much to write home
about here but uh the other game if we
can bring it up we actually see on the
on the right side of our screen uh
farusha it's the one with a big
Advantage arowana's bar jumps up as well
on the white side there uh just as I say
that and this is the position
computer not liking Black's last move at
all Breaking kind of the rules
conventional chess wisdom says don't
plant your knight on the edge of the
board to me this looks natural it looks
like black is targeting some of the
weaknesses white structure compromised
but maybe it's because of this Fabby
sensing the moment going forward leaping
forward with the white knight clearing
some squares for his Queen to come out
as well maybe this is a fearsome attack
for white very aggressive I mean that
right up my alley here I'm a very
aggressive player here hyper aggressive
I like to call her here I mean this is
very nice so what this looks like it
reminds me of a milnerbury gamut in a
way where many times in the milnerberry
Gambit a very aggressive gamma you can
play against the French defense you do
have the pawn on E5 Knight G5 is a move
the Bishops do sit on D3 and D2 you give
up the seat usually give up the D4 Pawn
there but it's already gone so giving up
the C3 Pawn is basically like the same
thing so we're going to bring our Queen
maybe even the H5 there's some
sacrifices on F7 very possible you can
just feel the the aggressiveness here
something's gonna happen in the next few
moves here and you need to be very very
cautious you can't even play H6 because
there's a knight F7 in there so you have
to be very very careful here that Knight
is very sick on G5 so really cool stuff
here from Fabi with Knight G5 and did
you see that
shaking his head he hates the outcome of
this French defense right out of the
opening feeling the pressure Knight G5
amazing move there by Fabi you want to
go shot Castle but that just invites the
queen jumping into H5 you're threatening
a meeting one on eight seven if black
was to go castling also all the
sacrifices that we have been pointing
out it just doesn't seem that black has
enough time instead to capture the C3
Pawn David that would also invite the
queen jumping on to F3 now you're eyeing
the F7 weakness and also X-Ring the
Knight on C3 with threats like Bishop G6
winning more material he yeah this would
be disastrous just to show this uh Tanya
Bishop takes Knight now would unleash a
discovered attack against this Knight
and when black recaptures white would
win a piece instead he's chosen a bit of
an ugly well I should shouldn't say a
bit of a strange looking move uh Bishop
to C6 what's the idea there I guess he's
just defending F7 with his Queen but now
there's no longer a threat against this
Pawn from the black queen and white does
have a important Tempo to get developed
and start attacking I'm feeling that
this queen needs to come out the
question is where does she sit on this
square the square the square plenty of
choice for white Daniel what you got
here oh I think black wants the castle
Queen side which is what I would call a
positional threat like if black can make
that move the king's not entirely safe
on the queen side but with white spawns
as ugly as they are it's hard to use
them as a coordinated Pawn mask to
shatter the queen side so I would
consider Queen F3 uh to to hold black
down by the F7 Pawn there's other ways
to attack you can also send the F Pawn
down the board F4 F5 and then even if
black castles Queen side that may not
solve all of Black's problems in the
center so a lot of options for Fabi but
the most important thing here I think is
whatever you do to account for the
possibility of black Castle in Queen
side and he picks a third option he puts
the queen on the g-force Quest so now
it's a big moment for shimanov to decide
will he go for that Queen side castling
trying to get his King to safety and
while he does just that we will take
this moment to check in on the other big
game alireza feruja who has been shaky
in his match against Dimitri kolars and
we see the eval Bar says that alireza is
back to doing what he does best getting
an advantage and how big is this it just
looks like White's the one who's created
all these attacks on the king side David
yeah I see this position I think of one
word or two words James Conti where is
the Checkmate it feels like all of
White's pieces are perfectly centralized
it feels Black's position is passive
loose I'm seeing uh hanging pieces all
over the place and that H7 Square
maybe there's a way to cash in I don't
see the immediate knockout blow but at
the very minimum white can bring the
final piece into the game that white
Rook on H1 can just slide into the
center all of White's pieces are at work
at play and uh black hanging by thread
here is having a threat tail that's the
move Tire get him off the board get him
off the board I think might survive
okay wow right you want to sacrifice I
do I do I want to sack you but of course
Bishop before it's just like he might be
holding right you know Bishop before the
problem is if 97 you had 96 if Queen D7
you have Knight F6 right that's why it's
so nasty I mean it's such a sick move
but Bishop B4 is like ah then you have
to take with the bishop and then maybe
he can take you take on H7 and you now
you have like it's not there it's not
enough yet it's not enough it's very
difficult here so we got to keep looking
right and if I was in a think tank here
see if we can figure this out Chad
let me just
tempting man oh my goodness what is this
bro where's the kill shot at so we need
to remove this Knight and this Knight
and then it will be checkmates well
maybe you just play like a Russian
school boy Knight takes F6 Knight takes
F6 and Bishop E5 okay was my idea yeah
Bishop F6 trying to force black to play
G6 and then just attacking normally
Bishop takes bishop and then H5 like
there's always the option of playing
without sacrificing which uh is more
attempting the older I get right but of
course this is not ideal I'm sure a
killer blow exists I can't find it
either
what is this oh Bishop D6 wow what ain't
nobody plan that man that's so hard to
do that's Gucci Gucci Bishop E6 has a
hard boom you guys got to explain this
bishop D6 the strongest move by the
engine what's the point it's so
counter-intuitive to exchange this
Bishop David yeah I agree I was looking
at this bishop thinking it's a tactical
Target it's loose uh White trade it when
you can try and win it uh that's why I
was kind of inclined towards bringing my
Rook across which I think is the second
best move but at least according to the
computer but bringing your Bishop in and
now if it's captured you'll support for
Choice it's like we said earlier you can
choose with two pieces uh to recapture
here it's really tempting for sure how
do you recapture your daily yeah what do
you do maybe you take with a rook now
you're threatening this uh kind of
capture this kind of destroying uh
maneuver here just to crash through on
H7 if black does Play Bishop takes E4 as
we mentioned earlier maybe you still
take back evaluation boss says it's
winning I don't think it's human yes I
don't think it's that natural I've got
to say but you are very active and uh
black is stretched so
difficult I've got to say for farouzia
to find this one time to wake up Mikhail
tall grandfather Towers what we call
them we are related as you see me and
Dania look exactly the light exactly and
we are related to Tau grandfather Yeah
I'm sure Simon would find that move as
well he would have played H4 in a
heartbeat easy all of this forced
clearly he's happy to see Harry the
h-pond advanced on the board can alireza
channel is that right now and find the
move Bishop D6 rookie one David you
mentioned it's the first move that came
to your mind the second best move in the
position but there is a lot of
difference between these two moves one
of them close to winning the other one
gets closer to leveling the game yeah
and it makes sense if black is able to
trade off a bunch of pieces black is a
pull-up remember so uh it feels like now
or never it was like that moment in the
last game for Russia had one shot he
could have won on the spot but he missed
it and things spiraled out of control so
cheat moment now for sure should burn
his time here and he has been doing five
minutes on this one move I'm expecting
it yes or no Bishop D6 that's so hard to
find and it really is I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say no because Bishop D6 is so
hard he's been spending five minutes
though so maybe he'll find it at the end
of the day but Bishop D6 is so difficult
I mean rookie sevens for Choice like
Knight F6 Bishop B5 like you mentioned
so many choices right Donya yeah it's
it's not like Bishop D6 itself is that
hard to see like it's on your radar it's
hard to understand why it's so much
better than the other moves right I
think the difficulty lies in
distinguishing between all the tempting
candidate moves which is an infuriating
type of difficulty because you're
sitting there your eyes are jumping
around at all the options then you look
up and you've got three minutes on your
clock yeah you've made no headways six
minutes for alireza time to make a
decision yeah what makes it so difficult
is that you're always trying to trade
those two knights which are the
Defenders it's not that easy to
understand that what you need to trade
is that Bishop on E7 that guards that D6
square and get your Rook into the attack
so again not an easy move to find but if
Ali Reza does it the victory will be in
his hand it is a big moment in the last
game instead of finding the winning move
he played Knight to E2 and that was a
big disaster giving the victory to
Dimitri colors Bishop C6 on the board
alire is a big think right now he's down
by three minutes on the clock it's it's
really interesting these top players
their instincts are just so good he has
tanked at the exact critical moment it
was the same in the last game he paused
he knew his senses were tingling his
Spidey sensors there he knew there was a
winning move but finding it is another
matter calculating it especially in
Rapid games uh at speed chess and yeah I
think if he had 45 minutes on his clock
he would spend most of it now and he'd
find that win he'd calculate his way to
Victory but this one is touch and go
this one Anything could happen if not
Bishop D6 momentum might turn a bit
later on
yeah this is very sharp chat this is
very sharp make sure you're doing a
tactics at home okay yes put your puzzle
rush in the chat what is your puzzle
Rush at home would you find Bishop D6 if
we didn't see it or we didn't have it
there for you to see already would you
have played Bishop D6 what's your
pleasure rush in the chat do your
tactics at home as he's trying to
calculate and figure this out
all right James it's not direct tactics
it's not sack sack and Checkmate it is
sort of got the Strategic Foundation of
getting rid of getting rid of a piece
that's sort of counter-intuitive for
white trading that dark Squad Bishop uh
the more alireza thinks the more I can
feel the tension the difference between
the best move and the second best move
is so big right now
yeah that's a huge difference crazy
seven and a half minutes on one move
that's literally half the time we
started the game with he better find
this move otherwise he will regret it a
little bit later on uh when the clock's
ticked down such a big moment huge
moment and now there's a sunk cost
effect where if you don't find the move
you don't have all that much time to
convert so now you better find it
alireza believes that he can win this
position with potentially less than
three minutes on the clock and King B1
kicking the can down the road king B1
that one this is that one hurts that one
hurts to see Daniel right it was just so
many prophylactic move he's he is
kicking the can down there I was gonna
use that pawn with ikaro but
um that's exactly what he's doing he's
just keeping the tension now in certain
variations David that King on C1 it
could have been vulnerable so I get what
he's doing he's just saying hey Dimitri
you've got a miserable position here you
find a move and maybe Dimitri will send
six minutes figuring out a way to
untangle here so I wouldn't you know
castigate this move entirely but
definitely alireza will be kicking
himself for not miss playing Bishop D6
yeah and I think he would have had the
same reaction inside to the reaction we
had here in the studio he'll be like oh
I don't want to play this but time's
ticking the clock's ticking down I have
to do something why not play a move
that's useful long term and we do say if
you Castle on the long side Castle Queen
side you should always spend an extra
Tempo tucking your king closer to the
corner it's just safer there in general
uh when the tactics begin so good kind
of
let's go move but just not the killer
bloat that we were expecting that's the
thing right if you want to play King B1
you play it after two minutes burning
eight minutes on the clock and King B1
on the board he decided not to play
Bishop D6 not to play rookie one it
feels like he's still finding his rhythm
today we've seen a shaky start from
alireza yeah no it's that it definitely
is the case I I still think he's the
heavy favorite in this game just because
of how difficult
spend for black in the long run but man
I mean two games left four minutes down
on the clock Ali Raza you know he better
step it up uh at the final part of this
game because if he loses the white
pieces to win on Demand with black
that's going to be real difficult and
he's sped up he's trading pieces I think
he's gonna stick that dark squared
Bishop on E5 and the attack burns on on
the board great call there by Daniel
Bishop E5 big threat David you want to
pick up that night and give mate on
eight seven yep big threat so easy reply
pretty much forced now just you have to
block that white Queen's diagonal
towards the H7 Pawn it's not a move you
want to play of course pushing Pawns in
front of your king when you're getting
attacked often leaves weaknesses behind
but needs must here and looks like the
only move to me unless I'm missing
something uh Dimitri most likely just
calculating the consequences behind that
decision and it's still very forcing
still Anything could happen I think in a
Blitz game I would choose white here
every time but here black has a bit more
time still are pulling up something to
play with and clearly momentum not
necessarily on foreign
puts a lot of white pieces Under Fire
but then there's like Knight takes H7 oh
my God the only reason I have those five
minutes back to calculate all those
lines right yeah this is definitely as
you see in the jobava London this is a
huge thing I mean the bishop we have the
bishop we got the queen we got the
Knight with the Rook on the H file you
sacrifice it if Knight H5 so this is
this is definitely what White's alley
lots of attacking chances here looking
good for white even though the eval Bar
says is equal practically this is
definitely a huge attack for white hair
choose chances and lots of chances for
black to go wrong yeah just to put some
of those moves you said on the board
James Knight takes porn looks like he
can grab a pawn but simply Rook takes
Knight you break up in this diagonal
again boom Checkmate on the board uh so
you cannot contemplate this one for
black if you go back a few moves uh here
uh Daniel you mentioned Knight to G4
maybe this is the key it's on the board
David wow it's on the board hitting this
bishop hitting this Knight and the
evaluation bar doesn't react just crazy
best news in the world
chess players that's the dream
[Music]
that's crazy bro you mentioned another
move Knight takes porn this looks like a
killer king takes Knight would walk into
a discovered check a double check your
Force back and Checkmate again all of
these lines lead to Rome they all seem
to lead to Checkmate but here I guess
you're not obliged to take back this
Knight you could for example take back
this bishop and uh the evaluation by
react but the game goes on it would end
up with black having two pieces for a
rook looks good so I think you're right
Dania just dropped back and uh just
again kick that can further down the
road H6 and G5 and once the king side
dries up I mean black is up a pawn which
I've actually forgotten about I didn't
see that so black consolidates that time
advantage and that extra Pawn alireza is
now in serious danger of losing this
game Yes Man chess is brutal man I mean
What a wicked attack here looked great
and then Cola it is showing the strength
of kolars winning the first almost
winning he was up he should have won the
first game chess is brutal like that he
loses right when's the second game and
this one defending like an absolute
machine right now as he's defending this
attack of course Ali Reza had his
chances Miss Bishop D6 we don't blame
him it was an engine like uh the uh move
there and an engine like follow-up you
just had to find all the moves here he
wouldn't didn't find it here now we have
this position here where he's trying to
figure out what to do here and he's
getting lower on time as we keep talking
Knight eight seven he goes for it yikes
and a mistake according to the engine
Dimitri coloss just sitting back taking
a sip of water that pretty calm stuff
but uh farusha he's gambling now he's
going all in just because he feels
momentum was turning and okay Knight
takes Bishop I thought was the most
natural move yeah what was the move what
else is there to do yeah that's a good
question Bishop F4 like David I'll check
this while you guys uh talk through
what's happening now but apparently
black missed a big opportunity
okay that was never going to be found
moving the black Rook after Knight takes
H7 decisive Advantage but never gonna
happen chat now it is nine and Bishop
versus Rook how weak is the black king
that's the big question
I know what you think I don't think it's
the same week no more bro there's
obviously alirez has messed up it's
clear that black is in the driver's seat
now problems if you play H takes G6
black and recapture the queen nastiest
news of all time when the Queens get off
the board then it's basically a two
result game so all Reza has to keep that
pawn on the board maybe play out four he
goes rookie one tries to attack in the
center it's gonna be a wild ride here
the rest of this game wow gonna be a
wild ride the problem is where do you go
after black drops the knight in
attacking this Rook I'm also seeing not
yet but later on the Black Knight
plonking itself in the center of the
board dominating closing lines as well
uh it definitely feels like the stakes
are far higher for furition than they
are for colors if callers can survive
the next five moves it might be just
simply winning for black big drama in
the alireza Dimitri board but also we've
got big update coming in from Fabi again
Shimano this is their round three but if
Fabi wins this game it is match over
that position on the king side it looks
like it is heading there this main six
he's
this Maiden six you got Bishop F6 you
got Rook G you got sack here like
whatever you want to do you can do it in
this game right here the Rooks attack
right now so do you just pick up the B7
Pawn or it's hard to imagine sacrificing
the rook and going for the mate you
might be able to do that oh my God
position so nice you might be able to go
I have two words for you dark squares
dark squares exactly yeah if you cut the
board in half if you just look at the
the kind of uh four rows on the right e
to H white just has all the heavy pieces
black only has a king
simple as that black queen is so far
divorced for my king right now she'll
never be able to defend yes to I think
go up take that B7 pawn and champagne
child support either yeah
it's actually hard to imagine and the
pieces coming to the black King's rescue
there's just nothing the bishop on D7
can't contribute anything to the king
side the two Rooks are on the queen side
the Queen's super far away hard to find
its way back and Fabiano caruana on the
brink of not just a game Victory but a
match Victory making it look very smooth
he is taking a thing to put the
finishing touches he can't just simply
grab the B7 pawn and as Daniel you
mentioned no need to rush no need to
start calculating all those sacrifices
because there's nothing in the world
that's going to stop Rook G3 and Bishop
F6 next no and and fabi's enjoying this
right he's not sipping his coffee
because he doesn't seem to have a
beverage next to him but if he did he'd
be sipping it right now he knows that
there's about seven paths that lead to
Victory I think he's going to take on B7
your ultimate Allegiance is to winning
the match right you're not trying to
write a tactics because my coach used to
say you're trying to win the game and
Fabio's trying to find the most
efficient way to do it there we go yep
he takes the pawn and uh we saw
shimano's body language a few moments
ago he was kind of rubbing his head then
he leaned back as if like oh why am I
even playing chess I have that feeling
all the time these days he needs to find
one way to fight on he does try and get
the Queens off the board he takes the
pawn back clever move but the problem is
this tension between the Queens can
simply be blocked right and you can push
uh the white d-pawn forward no Queen
trade for you and the attack will
continue uh there we go very since uh
kind of simple sensible play that from
Fabi still looks deadly White's gonna
crash through very very shortly
amazing to notice that how black can
actually get both the queen and the Rook
to the first rank you can give a check
and see one you can arrive with your
queen to D1 the whites King is so safe
on G3 there's absolutely no check once
the king gets to G3 meanwhile the bishop
on D7 hangs Bishop F6 Queen G5 ideas
always on the board and it just looks
like Black's attack has no Firepower
yeah game over simply he gives a check
indeed and uh when the white king moves
I think he okay he doesn't resign yet
but he does drop his Rook back that uh
pattern is going to emerge surely white
can just jump in with the bishop maybe
or maybe you have to be slightly careful
here sorry G4 yeah a bishop six Rook
takes D4 Queen G fire Rook G4 or G4 yeah
maybe just from D3 yeah Lazy Man's moves
Rook F3 also looks good oh Rick Affairs
are like that definitely a fan how about
D7 Bishop F6 just trying to have some
fun oh Tanya just don't care about
nothing sack it all this game over
yeah yeah that's nice feels like all
works yeah everything works now for
Fabian he still has over two minutes
against just 10 seconds for shimanov as
long as he finds any sensible move here
Bobby will win I want to see Rook D7 on
the board I don't know if it works or
not David but it's so pretty it's so
impractical but it's so pretty at the
same time yeah that is Pretty Ricky so
yeah right yeah yeah it's like when your
TV
[Applause]
put her in there
rookie four Queen takes a seven
yeah it's just clean up cleanup shop
here no time to win the white Rook black
queen if she if she went to take that
white Rook last move the black Rook
would have dropped off so now Fabi
making a bit of a face there maybe
realizing it's not as easy as he thought
it would be uh yeah go and take that
pawn defend your Rook at the same time
extra bishop and ongoing attack I wonder
if Queen C5 was a move there Dania and
then if Rook takes you take on f8 is
there a mating idea there Rook F7 after
that maybe he Rook G7 maybe just prepare
something similar definitely was it
possible takes check oh Rook d8 would be
made there oh my goodness no but but
black screen takes D7 though oh yeah
correct that's awesome
does win the first match of the
quarterfinals and what an end it's been
in this game Rook D7 we do see Alexander
shimanov he is disappointed it started
bright and good for Shimano but Fabi
kept it under control impressive play
there by Fabi and Seminole we see him on
the camera the first game it could have
been very different that's what's eating
on him right now because you he wins
that first game it's a completely
different story you're more in Jordan
Bend Forest territory you know he
expects a lot of himself these 2600s
yeah they know that they're The
Underdogs but that doesn't mean they're
any less disappointed speaking of
disappointed Dimitri will be
disappointed if he doesn't carry this
upset through he's got along with Jordan
a great chance to score a massive upset
what is going on here 16 seconds for
Reza and a mad position look at that
black king it's absolutely in the wild
yeah if the Queens come off black is
winning no doubt about that the Black
Knight and black Bishop will be far
superior to one of the white Rooks but
with Queens on the board that black king
is feeling really really exposed it
doesn't have any clothes on right now
it's gonna be hit by the white Rooks by
the White Queen okay he's dropping back
trying to curl up into a ball
defensively here
I don't see any knockout for white here
you want to line up your Rooks three oh
you're gonna move you just double The
Works wow he made that with uh wait a
few seconds on the clock six seconds
here that's tough it's very tough to do
yeah great move Queen H7 check is a
paper Tiger but Ali Ras are trying to
use all available files now he's
starting checkmate sort of still the
rookie eight meets with Rook f8 so the
king kind of sliding away all right but
maybe rookie seven is worth playing here
to get that pair of Rooks off the board
yeah you can uh if you can trade pieces
you will be loving life but right now
wow there's a steal from Cars calling
White Bluff saying there's no threat and
maybe he's right the black king running
out into the open now there's a triple
Checkmate
96 96 might be the only move oh what a
move there that's sick I love 96. oh my
God 96 and avoid picks up the night
White's the one who gets checkmated on
B2 made it dropper threat in why not
faruch only has six seconds to react
will he find it
oh my God Queen takes Port The Black
Queen on the diagonal coming and taking
the pawn in front of the white king
White's Queen has to swoop back and
defend uh-oh what happened I don't like
that move G5 baby
getting off the board what happened here
he blundered me oh my goodness
it hurts and that's it a one movement
blunder by alireza ferocia and Dimitri
colors and he was winning too if you had
played G5 White's in charge there
let's see that I think it was a mouse
slip I think he was bringing his Queen
to F5 maybe and uh he would have been
winning oh he wins a piece I think he
wins a piece but uh horrible horrible
muscle and heartbreak for far Asia
because he did make the move Queen to
see to defending that mating one and as
David is pointing out it could have been
a big ma slip we do have action on one
more board remaining Abdul satro of
going with that apron and to me it looks
like an Unstoppable air Pawn
looks like it should be but the black
Rook will come behind and the white
truck will go forward yeah you push your
Pawn now one square if you could get
your bishop and sacrifice it for that
apron somehow you live to find another
day the problem is the black Bishop is
so far away from hitting that white
apron yeah I think you're right game
over
rook d8 in the air maybe even Knight A5
Rook A5 in the air that A7 Pawn is
definitely getting to that square for
promotion we see on our score line
Fabiano caruana has taken the match
victory in three rounds not a big
disaster for alireza firuja means that
he has to win on demand the final game
of the rapid to level the score and in
this one not a back wins this he wins
the match
yup I think we will see the first
decided match or the second decided
match I should say in a moment after
Carolina won his two I'll do Satora for
leaning back he knows he's got this one
in the bag just no source of counter
play for black just won't move too slow
we're just gonna put it out there I mean
he's been playing so good guys I mean
abusive has been playing I mean he's
already you know youngest well rapper
Champion ever but like he really is
playing out of his mind he's someone
that people aren't really talking about
as much of course because you don't have
the Heavy Hitters here but abdusitorov
is one that is coming for it all
yeah that's it we start getting ready to
resign you can see the body language
White's about to make a new Queen it
will cost black as rook and okay he goes
Pawn hunting okay good move actually but
I would just promote anyway I mean yeah
it happened big deal Rook A4 one upon
congrats cute you want a medal
I think we will see Jewel hit the resign
button now tough day for him just I'm
just sort of looking so good looking
inspired and the white Rook will decide
this game uh okay he's fighting on the
white King's simply going to move
towards the king side now and
those pawns are going nowhere
wow
game over any moment now
and now we see Knight D4 he's up an
entire Rook on the board and Jules
playing on seconds but the clock doesn't
matter it is a dead lost position but
this loss would mean uh that the match
is over as Abby satural with one and a
half points we'll wrap it up in just
three rounds a check even if the king
moves forward the Knight can start
checking not much to fight for with
black here those pawns are never getting
down the board and I think he's just
resigned because King E5 Knight F3 picks
off the G Pawn of the Satora with just
enough end game technique to convert
this very difficult end game you can
find it in varetski's end game manual
page 478. that's correct he makes it
happen Notre back on form on point he's
winning
he has a one-owned style as he wraps it
up in three games just like Fabiano
caruana what a performance by and we've
seen some incredible moments in this one
such amazing attack David you gotta tell
us your highlight my highlight from this
round was that game that dramatic game
between ferusia and Carlos ended so
abruptly and we have to go in slow
motion uh just to take you through what
happened here it looks like the black
king is under attack and indeed farooja
slid his Rook across threatening to
bring his Rook to E8 with a Checkmate
the black king would be trapped instead
nasty counter threat dropping the Knight
back blocking that file the e-file and
threatening a check made with black Zone
on B2 fuchsia of course spotted this
queen C2 Rook E7 and this was the moment
of heartbreak for furja I think at least
my theory is that he wants to play Queen
to F5 pinning the black queen and once
the black queen is traded white would
win the Black Knight due to a pin on the
e-file too but instead he Mouse looked
he dropped his Queen on that diagonal
now no defense to B2 and Checkmate the
white King was the one that perished
big heartbreaking moment therefore
alireza farouza it means that he has to
win the next game on demand and he will
be playing with the black pieces these
are the score lines going into the final
rapid game hikarnakamura Jordan van
first level at one and a half a piece we
could see an Armageddon in that one and
of course we've got alireza against
Dmitry alireza has to win to force a
playoff yeah so that will be also a
potential Armageddon bit before that
alireza with the black pieces need to
score that win the two players who have
managed to wrap up their match one of
the quarterfinals Fabiano caruana and
Notre back abdisattro and we are being
joined by Fabi Fabi welcome
congratulations
thanks Tanya
amazing match today terrific play and I
have to ask you Fabi accessible Masters
you had such a great run in that one
you're just fresh out of a hot victory
in Romania the grand chest star and you
made it look easy today you feeling good
about the chess
yeah well today could have been very
different
overall yeah overall it's very very good
um I blundered G5 in the first game so I
was I had a very bad position after like
eight moves with the white pieces
and uh
but then everything went very smoothly I
was a bit surprised I thought I I could
easily get mated with my king on E1 kind
of surrounded by my pieces which can't
move
but uh and somehow worked out I I won
that game and after that it was pretty
smooth I wasn't too worried
um I think I was also slightly worse in
the third game but never in real danger
and yeah overall that first game was
really essential today
you feel confident and are you feeling
like you're
like about that but it's the last few
tournaments have been pretty successful
I mean if we're counting the chessful
Masters
and uh and the grand chess Tour event in
Romania those were two quite successful
events but you never know how form is it
can go up it can go down and a lot of it
is also based on circumstance so
um let's say a few things change in the
tournament and you can either have one
of your best tournaments or a tournament
which doesn't go very well a lot of it
is really down to details that you
um that you kind of know if you're in
the in the heat of it but you you might
not see from the side so I know how
quickly fortunes can change
and tell you how important is it for you
to get that ticket into the season final
you are of course one of the favorites
in the Chaska cup
yeah it's really important uh because I
I haven't let's say
um I'm in a good position overall in the
tour but I have unfortunately last last
event in the chessful Masters I didn't
qualify directly to the final but that's
the ultimate goal and in terms of points
I'm doing very well so if I keep up
consistency then then hopefully
um I might even make it on points
but it's still a bit early to say and uh
you know it's it's very important of
course I think Hikaru said that the most
important thing is to get in the top
three because that also books you a spot
for the next event uh and and I think
there's a lot of sense to that
although ultimately the goal is to win
but
um but it's a huge privilege of course
if you can keep playing division one
time and time again because that gets
you guaranteed points
an awesome start there Fabi
congratulations for today and we wish
you all the best for tomorrow
takes his match in just three games and
the other player to do that is not a bag
of this
is joining us and he's joining us from
starvenger hello hi Nori back are you in
Norman right now
yes wow and it seems to have worked out
really well great match today tell us
how you're feeling
yeah it's very nice to to start with a
smooth Victory and I'm like I'm really
looking forward to to keep it to keep it
so
back you are playing division one off
winning
of the adjustable Masters how important
is that to get this spot in the chess
gate cup and how do you see your chances
going forward
it's very important for me because it's
it gives a chance to play against the
top guys which is very important to
to constantly playing against them is
very helpful and it's okay it's huge
honor for me to to play in division one
and I will try my best and yeah it's
looking great and I'm really really
looking forward to play a good chess
another back here also playing in of
course the Norway chess uh tournament
how excited are you for that tournament
what are your expectations and what's
next on your chess calendar after
norwichs
oh yes uh yeah it's huge hugely
important tournament for me
and uh yeah uh I have prepared uh almost
four
um
a couple of months uh and uh yeah
I'm really looking uh to play some
interesting chess and
uh yeah after Norway my I'll play in a
global chess League
sync it will be uh
a team championship so yeah I'm I'll be
playing there
I'm not about congratulations tremendous
first round here at the just get
government we wish you all the best for
tomorrow thank you thank you we really
appreciate your time not a bag of this
outro of and Fabiano caruana taking it
in just three games but the other two
matches the action is still on as you
will see that fourth and final rapid
game on the other side of the switch
break
[Music]
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing the
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids chess kid is
easy whether you're a parent helping
your child a coach managing dozens of
kids or a school of hundreds signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
at Magnus Academy we've taught chess to
a hundred thousand kids with Summer
around the corner we're gearing up for
camps
at online chess camps kids learn about
Chess in a safe fun environment from a
team of All-Star coaches
kids are grouped by skill level from
beginners up to national champions there
are never more than eight kids per coach
so every child gets plenty of attention
you might even get the chance to meet
Magnus and ask him a question or
challenge him to a game
each week has a different theme like
opening traps learning from your losses
or Magnus Carlson's best games
sign up by May 31st to get a 30 discount
join the 100
000 Kids and Counting that have learned
chess with Magnus chess Academy
of focus concentration performance
air things put you in control of air
pollutants that cloud your work from
home space
shifting your state with every breath
find your air of clarity now
foreign
needs to win on demand to force an
Armageddon Daniel prediction time are we
gonna see an Armageddon man I mean that
Maiden one that's going to be so hard to
survive that was and what made that
doubly heartbreaking wasn't just the
mouse up it was that Queen F5 ended the
game immediately as David So as Thule
pointed out I have no idea how Ali Rez
is going to fight that demon one thing
is for certain this is going to be
awesome what's stressful for the players
is fascinating for the commentators I
can't wait for both of our games and the
clocks are ticking Nakamura is ready to
go in round three with the white pieces
he did the side to level it out to shut
down the play but now Jordan ban Forest
will start with white James are we
expecting Jordan to be happy to take it
to the Army Garden or do you think he's
gonna try and push with white yeah I
think he's gonna try to push who white
here of course I mean we do want it who
normally get in here obviously that's
what we want right but I mean it's all
about what he wants you have to play
some solid chest here you are playing
Hikaru Nakamura here hikar was very very
strong we do have the white pieces we
want to take the chances that we have be
creative here play our game and hope for
the best
yeah he looks focused he looks nice and
focused and uh anything could still
happen I like the fact that Jordan was
able to kind of stabilize in that last
game
um didn't look like the biggest opening
success for Hikaru Nakamura but you're
stabilized and uh in terms of these
small mini matches that is so important
after you lose the most important thing
is to at least get on the scoreboard in
the next one and okay we're off and
India yeah Hikaru kind of going for his
main line no modern no C6 or G6 he's
playing what he normally plays and this
is a very old school line this three
Pawns in the center line it's been very
well known for several decades there's a
lot of force draws in this line so we
might be going straight for an
Armageddon here wow did you see hikaru's
reaction as soon as E4 landed on the
board he just looked away he was like oh
not this again so many times against
Wesley so but this time slightly spicier
version this one is not heading towards
any four straws
as far as I know at least Jordan banffer
is choosing a very ambitious line and
look at what he's done he's parked his
King on the F1 square that black knight
in the center of the board is actually
pretty much trapped but there is a way
to keep it alive if white hits it now
with the F Pawn which I think is going
to be Jordan's next move oh is it F3 is
it F5 I think so oh my goodness this is
sick spicy basket sauce in there wow the
green kind like the green bottles
Tabasco sauce the super hot stuff I
agree F3 and F5 finally someone who
likes the green saucer on the Red Sox I
do I know yeah we look alike do right
now that's crazy and is it surprising
that Jordan is thinking he was the one
who chose this opening variation it's
all been on White's terms so far he's
the one who forced this line and now
he's paused after hikaru's last move
this uh rash this opening Theory still
as far as I know it's still very
standard stuff maybe Jordan just kind of
thrown back that Icarus reacted
instantly this is not the time or the
place to freeze and show that you don't
know what you're doing you've done
you've dug your hole a little bit too
deep you should have played something
like a London system
if you didn't rush up on your theory so
danger time for Jordan who plays 92 and
prioritizes his development in Hikaru
are you surprised at that move he did
the classic car looking to the side
thing right I think that might be wrong
wrong but it's not logical right but
that's a probably a mistake by Jordan it
might be tilted That's a classic car
over here
[Laughter]
and there we go again the color look one
four three
meanwhile another game starting
in just a few seconds we will have
liftoff in this one as well Dimitri
colors has definitely been more
impressive today James of course Ali
Reza being a favor here but I mean first
off this is a C3 Cecilia me and Dania
are hype right now see through and David
elephant players C3 Cecil for the kill
okay now of course this is I mean very
impressive from Dimitri here he's also
saying you know farouza was a big
favorite but right now of course he is
on the back foot and with the secret
it's an excellent choice you can also
play it very aggressively even with the
new chessable word versions of stuff
they have out here it's pretty sick the
CJ Sicilian is a problem even Magnus has
a tweet you can Google it it says if you
ain't got a pro tip here uh play the
alapin I hate facing it the C3 is a real
thing yeah everybody hates facing it
David that's why we play it Queen A5 I
mean it's hard to play for a win here
there are some dubious lines Queen A5 D6
if you're early as a D5 Ed Knight F6 you
might have to play something dubious
just to get chances for a win here
because a draw doesn't cut he loses the
match with a draw exactly if you follow
any traditional paths any opening Theory
there will be white ways for white to
achieve a very solid position and that
will not suffice for for in the match
and okay already spent one minute yeah
he needs to do something he's trying to
figure out what to do with the Knight of
six version but that one's always draws
like draw or at least white has the fun
here I mean his wife is going to have
all the fun to say the least I think he
probably should have went maybe the D5
option or even someone like you
mentioned some of the sideline stuff
there's B6 there's Queen A5 there here
this is a Mainline stuff I'm thinking
now that I'm not aware of Knight G8
move you get that to D5 but once again
alirez are slowing down David you
mention it he needs to do something he
literally needs to do something in this
match he has to win uh James Cecil for
the kill Dimitri doesn't even need to go
for the kill he just needs half a point
to win this match absolutely and of
course lots of times with white you
actually can you just get great
positions with the C3 system it is quite
quite annoying to face from a sicilian
player's side it's just they get shot
they get a solid position they cut two
Pawns in the center when they go deep
Donya the prophets oh my God
the winning attempt tonight did she hit
he lost his absolute hero national
television in front of all these kids
Knight G8 is not a move but it is going
to be to try for a win here he must have
come up with that on the spot because if
he had prepared that beforehand he would
have played it immediately I mean 94
lost the Knight so
he would have at least played it
immediately it might be a bad move but
if you play it immediately or have
surprise value shock value Knight G8 uh
there is a kind of sister version of
this in the alakai defense where you
play Knight F6 or move one E5 and then
go back to G8 but
oh here just Black's giving white two
free moves white has space for free you
don't want to transpose into the French
defense Now by locking in your your
light Square Bishop as black because
then you've essentially given white
everything he could ever hope for and uh
yeah a bit of a dream position can
Dimitri hold his nerve here if you just
play sensible moves develops he's not
going to be in any trouble anyway I
think you have uh more experience here
too uh actually from me I know you like
Carol Khan here this is Carol cones Very
Carol Khan like he also may be French
too as well but of course if Knight F3
then you see Bishop G4 E6 and you have a
great French or some type of Carol
composition so I think it's a pretty uh
it's practically actually made a great
choice after Knight GA it was very
strange I've never seen this move ever
right but let's see okay it's not that
bad here but for white what do we do now
in these Bishop E3 or Bishop E2 maybe to
stop this uh Bishop development Bishop's
coming to F5 he's gonna play E6 and we
have ourselves some type of Carroll Khan
yeah I think you're right James we don't
want to allow blacks Bishop to come out
on an effective Square maybe pin any
White Knight so now he's asking the
question that's C8 it's all about that
piece black wants to play E6 over the
next two or three moves but you don't
want to lock in that piece you have to
pretty much bring it out now or if
you're going to suffer you're going to
get cramped and that could come with
consequences Daniel you play the caracon
as well yeah unfortunately
Bishop F5 is what you mean what you
wanted to play but there was Queen B3
forking the B7 and D5 it's almost like
you're playing this position down to
Tempe like you put your knight on F6 and
then brought it back to G8 he tries to
bring it back to H6 French style very
French influenced idea probably what you
have to do he has to also unbalance this
game because this type of structure as
solid as it is for white I mean he's got
to produce winning chances somehow I
think Knight H6 is the best that he can
do
and that is the explanation for the
strange opening play that we are seeing
by alireza he develops tonight to F6 and
falls back to G8 and now it takes it out
on the edge of the board aiming to try
to get it closer to the center from that
F5 square that is a lot of Night Moves
we are traditionally taught this is
advice for chess kid do not try this at
home you don't want to touch the same
piece twice out of an opening while
alireza does it four times it is his
attempt to create an imbalance in the
position and while action heats up in
this one let's use this opportunity to
jump over to the other game Jordan man
forest with the white pieces against
Hikaru Nakamura now it could potentially
go into an Armageddon we are seeing
opposite color Bishops but black does
seem to have the worst Pawn structure
yeah long term black has the worst Pawn
structure but short term the white king
may be a bit uncomfortable and uh
White's Pawns in the center as well
slightly uh I mean we would call them
hanging pawns I guess slightly
vulnerable potentially if black can
arrange the right setup so anything
could happen here uh Georgian does have
the opportunity if he wants to be greedy
to grab the pawn on e4 but I think that
would have come with consequences so
first he tucks his King away watch out
for H4 for the score it's gonna happen
over the next few minutes James that's
right baby boy age four for the score
you already know your H4 H5 looks good
maybe Rook H4 in that idea as well you
develop The Rook via the H file you see
this a lot in French type structures H4
H5 you develop The Rook to H4 you hit E4
and the King can actually hide on H2 it
almost looks like you castled and Rook
lift somehow some way so in fact this is
on his radar here black is going to try
to stop that I actually don't see how
yet these pawns on D4 and C4 are quite
good yeah Rook C8 might be quite
annoying there I might have to go
quickly e to get out of there because
the bishop d5s and queen B5 bishop b5s
and stuff like that it's possible I like
both sides here actually believe it or
not it's positions where you can like
both sides here so I do like white for
the the uh the ideas of H4 H5 and Rook
lifting via the H file but I also like
black the like we can double on the f
file right now and potentially even if
we're able to move the F6 Rook move the
Knight somewhere and maybe go Knight G4
in some cases there one day maybe even
be a rook F3 very extreme but put
something on F3 at some point with
sacking possibilities the Queen's
already on the fifth rank they could
swing over to the king side Richie six
nasty wow yeah he's going for his King
H4 though what's happening here yeah it
looks like this is gonna gain time for
white
G4 Square so maybe it's worth playing H3
we're free King H2 we're part of the
crew oh okay Chef one and we're done
G4 looks so artificial right now but it
can't be attacked for a long time
are we sure about that it feels like
Queen E2 may be hitting the Rook
maybe you cement it with the pawn I was
thinking Knight F6 at some point I could
think about eliminating this Knight it
does feel so weird this Rook on G4 it's
either very strong or it's very bad
right uh that's the thing I'll say uh
maybe it's very strong maybe if I seem
deeper uh but yeah risky stuff either
way for black
yeah super risky especially for a fourth
round game where a result would mean one
player wins if this ends in a draw we
would have an Armageddon but is it fair
to say that draw in this position is the
least likely outcome
this is a crazy well okay we didn't have
that crazy uh modern game where we
thought he was going to win the ordin
that is but paid H5 I like it stopping
H5 himself Knight F6 Queen E2 yeah H6
what is going on we're just I think we
would need hours to dissect this one to
fully understand it again that black
Rook collects it looks like it stands
alone but uh still the idea here is to
stop Jordan's Rook that white Rook on H1
from entering the game uh you mentioned
it James if it could have slid up to the
fourth rank it could have activated kind
of uh horizontally there but
yeah hard to find a plan for white I've
got to say if you can't activate that
Rook
whose position would we choose here yeah
I don't know what you think it's like
the feeling I I got in college and I
would open up the test booklet in math
class like okay I can answer exactly
zero of these questions I don't really
understand anything that's going on here
I would just take black because I think
his King is marginally safer and this is
the downside of pushing that Harry the
h-bomb all the way up up to H5 if you
play King H2 that King can be sent back
on Demand with Rook H4 check and the G4
square is a lasting weakness one day
perhaps a knight could replace the Rook
so Jordan trying to remedy that by
pushing the Rook up to H3 first and
opening up that little envelope that
hiding space for his King which doesn't
need to move away from G1 yet but you're
playing Hikaru Nakamura you can't be too
safe look at this strange maneuver
Knight F1 Knight H2 because the uh The
Rook is trapped what a stupid maneuver
but it actually works I mean Knight F1
maybe I mean well now he has Knight H5
there so that's a very good move because
I was definitely going to trap this Rook
Knight F1 Knight he's two you have no
squares we have to give it to exchange
for Rook G5 so now don't have that plan
and I'm just trying to figure out how to
untangle my pieces here are we sure
James maybe you've just uh kind of
stumbled across the jackpot that
stumbled across the Golden concept
because if you drop your knight back yes
this Pawn can be taken right but
suddenly you can throw a pawn in the way
breaking the connection
between I just realized that Bishop A4
is here and it gets super complicated we
need to what is going on
it's crazy here Black's Rook is barely
surviving Badness wow this is total
Madness and uh like you say maybe uh if
you don't want to kind of reroute the
night yet first you bring your queen
across and this idea is on tap for later
this Rook trapped but uh just so
complicated he goes for it wow that's
good shooting chaos yeah look I'm a
creative player myself creative players
I love that type of Chess right got the
Richer reports the Jordan van Forest is
the Daniel naroditskis of course right
so I love this type of Chess creative
very creative Knight of one night H2
with the idea of trying to trap the
world create a little bit of chaos here
he actually won a chaotic game like that
sacking his Queen earlier so right up
his alley yeah if you think he played
that one on feel on instincts or is it
pure calculation he played it relatively
quickly I would have tanked there for
five minutes I'm gonna say before kind
of going into such a forcing line Daniel
was a Coe there or was it intuition he's
managed to this time so so well and
honestly no matter how this match goes
just hats off to Jordan he's been he's
played such inspired chess even the game
that he lost I mean he was off with a
bang he was that close to winning it and
he hasn't let it got to get to him he
doesn't want this to go into an armaged
and he wants to win with white and I
mean Hikaru facing the threat of Knight
H2 if he loses that exchange he
basically loses the game there's no
compensation to be found so he might
have to take the plunge and snap that
pawn off on H5 and he might have to
change his pants there but Hikaru often
gets away with that kind of stuff
and uh he's puzzled he's her puzzled
puzzled
it's such a weird position I'm
questioning everything
um yeah he's struggling to come up with
a way to on kind of untrap that Rook
even and I don't see it I think he has
to just bite the bullet and take off
that white H Pawn and hope for the best
and he voluntarily put it there with the
Rook to F6 Rook G6 Rook G4 kind of just
getting self-trapped in the position and
great call James are with that night
maneuver we've been talking about Jordan
van for his being one of the most
creative players well at least in this
field he's really known for these ideas
and just how quickly he found it he
keeps the pressure on the clock
currently a big threat on the board
coming up with Knight H2 targeting that
black crook once again in this match
in big trouble and I have to say when we
started the day this was not an outcome
that many of us could have predicted
yeah I'm not even close I mean Hikaru is
we definitely knew who origin is going
to bring it to him here but we didn't
think it would be like this of course
especially as he car was being
resourceful so strong as he is wins
everything sort of a bully in a way but
today in fact this is a completely even
to say the least Jordan is very
impressive from him
amazing stuff by Gordon van Forest he
does March down with Harry the h-pond
gets the king artificially gosled on G1
just some amazing plan when we talk
about Harry the H Pawn we of course have
to bring in
Simon he's joining us Simon you've got
another update for us from division two
uh I do yeah and uh yeah such an
exciting game going on there though we
won't take you away from it too much and
obviously always use Harry if you're in
doubt this is the key Rule and we have
some some more results from division two
coming through and the big one we said
at the start of the day was fedexv
versus mamajarov both of these players
incredibly strong players they could
easily win that group and it went all
the way down to Armageddon and it went
with fedexv winning that game winning a
very important game to knock out Mama
jar of so very hard news for Mama jarov
there very tough pairing for him but
fedesv has won that result other results
in that division Pavel ilyanov went
through as well uh the Ukrainian against
Folger vashulov and there's one playoff
still going on with Dmitry adri aching
playing against neon so um they're
getting near to the the final results
there and division three loads of games
going on still they're into the second
round of the day there so there's a lot
to update but I think we should probably
get back to Harry the H Paul and our our
big game over there shortly
lines for that assignment wow fetusive
the big fish taking it in the Armageddon
against chakriar mama diarov uh I have
to say Daniel that sounds more like a
final match-up in an elite tournament
than a first round of division two that
was a brutal pairing for fedes and he
says I'm gonna take that pairing and I'm
gonna embrace it and he defeats chakra
Ahmad yarov that is an incredible result
of course just the first step on a very
long journey but what a first step it is
and it also looks like Jordan man Forest
has taken all the right steps into
staying in the Winner's bracket
currently he is in driver's seat Rook d8
has been the move of choice and we see
Jordan up by four minutes now D4 is
protected with that Bishop on E3 and he
continues with his plan and there's an
exchange sacrifice is this enough
compensation
wow and he gives it up for the bishop so
that the D4 Pawn is softened up and so
that when the queen recaptures on G5 he
gets the threat of e3 so very smartly
done by ikar making the most out of a
difficult situation David I think yeah
uh really really creative way of
sacrificing and uh not panicking
actually that he will go material down
as you say Daniel Bishop takes Rook most
likely move to happen the queen will
recapture suddenly some hints at a
threat against this G2 Square uh not
just that but two pawns Under Fire this
D4 Pawn no longer protected and also
remember that this little guy Harry
about to fall off the ball too if the
Black Knight comes in suddenly there
could be danger for whites and yeah
white is what material but what remains
in the right position isn't too
attractive this Rook not really playing
a part this Rook feeling a bit clumsy
suddenly but it's actually the night
that's worst of all it now needs to kind
of Trace its steps back to the center
and it does take a few Tempe to
reactivate that piece so really clever
stuff from Nakamura I've got to say I
like it initially I was very skeptical I
saw this position I thought
your winning material with weight is
just going to be a mop-up job after that
just uh kind of trade down and win with
the extra material but Nakamura clever
clever stuff really sophisticated as
we're used to uh well we're kind of
expect from him these days you know one
thing about Hikaru is their
resourcefulness of course yes I'm going
to lose some material here of course I
maybe have got two ambitious with the
Rook G4 thing and stuff but Knight H2
and then I lose my exchange but I'm
giving it back in a minute it gives me
initiative and also in Practical chances
of course H5 is hanging I do have
pressure on G2 as well you play D5 wow
wow that's strong that's real strong
another amazing move because now you
take on G5 and then you can play H6 and
Harry the h-man lifts the fight another
day Gary the G Pawn might be under some
fire and you've given up Desmond the
d-pawn but and Kyle the king might be in
some trouble there in the corner well
that's David the default that's going to
run through now and win the game for
black but uh yeah really clever stuff
breaking the connection between the
black queen and her rook and I think
like you say Daniel just uh trade here I
think that last variation I was a bit
careless kind of rushing through with
the Whiteboard first trade-off on D5 and
next move I'm not sure which way black
recaptures but you could think about
pushing forward with Harry or finally
re-route that Knight as previously
mentioned the Knight sits on the E3
Square it will be unbreakable and I
think White's extra material will
eventually count wow classy stuff from
your most players playing extremely well
in this game gotta say hey D5 is an
amazing move right you could have just
simply picked up the Rook but first he
disconnects the queen and the rook and
he wants to destroy that pawn structure
that is some super GM level chest that
we're seeing D5 love it he's still up on
the clock and for Hikaru Nakamura it is
a tough moment but he decides to keep
going Bishop A4 hits the queen so white
still doesn't have time to pick up that
Rook on G5 you simply sidestep with the
queen to E2
sidesteps somewhere I'm not sure where
the White Queen goes E2 does protect the
H5 Pawn that could be very relevant a
bit later on the black Rook might
survive though the BlackRock could just
sidestep oh
might get trapped anyway there we go
queenie2 on the board I'm wondering
whether black can keep counter-attacking
at some point
I I don't really see anything else here
maybe you just have to sacrifice and
hope for the best yeah Tanya you're
right Queen E2 the Black Brook is still
trapped where to run to
not looking good for Karu Nakamura right
now it's on the board and actually on
the clock too
tough situation here Queenie do the
funding by the H5 Bond it might be
tempting to put black black screen on C3
hitting that Rook on A1 but eventually
once that Rook moves the queen on C3
will come under Fire with that other
Rook on H3 so not going for that Hikaru
makes the move rookie five and we see
the eval bar creep further up for Jordan
van Forest we do also get an update on
his air quality it says it's poor but
his chest has been fantastic anything
but poor but now he's got a big this is
again what Hikaru does he forces you to
make decisions so rookie five isn't all
bad there's Bishop D4 there's Bishop F4
Jordan though he is he is on fire right
now Bishop D4 he might snap that Knight
off the board then E4 is going to fall
Hikaru is so close to collapsing here
yeah I love the fact that it wasn't just
anyone commenting on the air quality it
was Fabby and Fabi says bad air quality
but it seems fresh and this play is just
uh just mind-boggling right now Jordan
van Ferris despite the air quality he is
feeling inspired Queen C7 not the move
you want to play that Rook is trapped
now you can take it or you can maybe
even delay a move or two uh is there
anything better grab the material yeah
probably just grab the material I am
looking around here I was trying to see
if F4 works but he just goes Rick F5 he
just takes it yeah
oh and there it is Ricky won he gets out
of the way
yeah why is your sub material I mean wow
great chest from Jordan today yeah black
has just one Pawn for the uh Rook for
Bishop right now the exchange as we say
and I don't think it should be enough
there's plenty of open files the white
Rooks will eventually find their way in
I really want to get that white knight
into the game I'm not sure if you spring
It Forward try and trade off those white
Knights that's the first move that comes
to my mind there might be some tactics
there though to avoid uh oh I did
blunder I think
let's just show this on the board maybe
the most natural move isn't always the
best one and uh I wanted to say Knight
G4 why not trade things off and then I
realized whoops pieces on the same
diagonal this is how Jordan lost earlier
in the day against uh Nakamura he put
his two Rooks on the same diagram you
better stop talking about it David or
you know what's gonna happen oh
commentators maybe bring it around the
other way if in doubt uh you also have
plenty of tempting moves this one comes
to mind maybe trying to get the queen in
behind uh attacking the black Bishop in
the process looking good for white
either way
a lot of options Pleasant ones for
Jordan van for us but he needs to make
sure he takes a decision and he does it
in time currently Hikaru is also putting
pressure on that H5 Pawn 985 Knight F4
ideas in the air Knight F1 rerouting it
to try to bring it to that E3 Square
potentially just centralizing the pieces
it's interesting how that Rook on H3
that white has a creative way to develop
does become a strong piece but my first
question is can black get greedy here
can Hikaru pick up the H5 Pawn with the
Knight and there might be GG it might be
knighty3 and I'm hitting the Rook you
got to be careful because I have a queen
C4 check so that might force a rook to
C5 there even Queen takes E4 I think is
a simple option I think I might go
Bishop D7 or Bishop B5 and just play for
a win here yeah drop the bishop back uh
why not play for a win we've seen him
win from worst positions but uh okay
Knight takes Pawn just to show that
variation even Queen takes E4 and at the
very end after the Queen's come off this
piece attacked this piece attacked like
struggling to survive okay he drops his
Bishop back the hallway going for the
same Pawn Yeah but I'm amazed that what
Daniel just said that Hikaru potentially
could be trying for the win here it is
down in exchange but we know well not
Bishop D7 but just one step more back he
does put pressure on H5 and now that
Rook on H3 well it's kind of far away
from getting active so Hikaru still has
the time to make more of his peace
activity there's definite compensation
on the board
yeah when it comes to Hikaru I always
just think stability if he stabilizes a
position no matter what material count
it is no matter how bad it looks he
always finds a way to wriggle out in the
momentum turns he outplays his opponent
and it could be one of those situations
black despite the material deficit has
stabilized it feels like he's kind of
controlled defended everything for now
and it's definitely up to Jordan to kind
of prove that he can hang with Hikaru
when the tactics begin and look at that
white rope almost all the way home that
white king not happy it looks like it
castled and then it's kind of uncastled
that white Rook trapped
getting the momentum and the pressure
with Bishop G4 hitting that queen as
well now the good news for Jordan is
that he can start pinning that Rook on
D5 and we saw Jordan shaking his head
he's not happy with the last few moves
and how this position has played out he
kind of doing a little Bishop dance
Bishop here Bishop D7 Bishop C6 life's
better
at least in Practical terms
yeah looks beautiful what does white
even do I don't even want to consider
opening up this diagonal taking that
pawn in the center it feels like
something bad's gonna happen that black
Bishop poised to strike we can look at
that if you want the eyes but uh rookie
five in the end yeah at a minimum
absolute minimum gross let's just show
this Jordan he's caught between a rock
and a half place right now if he takes
this Pawn disaster will likely strike
and this move unleashes the diagonal
here Queen takes Rook of course this
ends in Checkmate similar to the
farouzia game from a bit earlier so you
don't want to touch that if you don't
touch that your Rook is trapped your
knight is stuck your piece is here a bit
stuck too
Nakamura he's so good it is it's
incredible to watch him play sometimes
especially when you're done exchange
you're like oh yeah like you just feel
like you're winning but you're not in
fact they say you have to beat these
players many times in one game right so
it's very difficult here I mean you even
see like Knight G4 E3 possibilities
because the Knight defense E3 in some
cases right you're just trying to open
up loosen some things you want to play
E3 yourself here not allow a queen takes
E3 so I do like the idea of my G4
pushing E3 at some point um but it's
also a very very scary for the white
pieces look at The Rook on H1 like what
do we do with this maybe Rook H3 but
then okay maybe we repeat and we go to
Armageddon but being up in exchange
that's kind of hurts you know especially
white pieces you hand over white to
Hikaru into this Armageddon game right
Knight F1
what repetition I I don't think Hikaru
is even thinking about died right now
he's playing for the initiative James
and you can feel with white when you
make moves like Rook H1 Knight to F1 the
things have gone wrong what Jordan wants
to do is plants that Knight on E3 once
that Knight gets there you defend the G2
Pawn you put pressure on uh the D5 Rook
now unfortunately I don't think black
has time to actually sack that E4 Pawn
you want to develop your Bishop
activated it gets greedy Knight F4 is
coming in Daniel you've been saying it
for a while Hikaru for the win in this
one and that's the thing now he's got
two pawns for the exchange so he's not
even really done material what does that
mean that means that even if the Queens
are swapped it that isn't necessarily in
White's favor any longer so after like
93 Knight F4 white could play Queen G4
and in that situation Hikaru could
absolutely trade queens and still be
playing for the win in that end game
moreover the A3 Pawn is a serious
weakness the attack could continue in
the end game something like Rook A5 or
Rook D3 as David is indicating
I mean all of a sudden all these new
doors have opened up for Hikaru now that
he has two pawns for the exchange and
Jordan is suddenly on the ropes how well
do you have to play to beat this guy
it's crazy it's also on the board 93-94
is on the board his decision now is is
he going to trade is it force it doesn't
look like because G2 is defended but I
mean we don't take it I mean at night is
menacing and even Gary kasperoff says a
knight on F5 wins games now of course
it's in reverses the F4 Knight this
Knight is very strong on F4 luckily we
have the counter night on E3 to defend
G2 but I mean if you move the queen you
probably may go to A2 to try to pin the
rook and then there might be some Rook
D3 Rook takes E3 options available at
some point I mean really do you trade to
Queens or not as the question here
Donald
now we know this is going to be a hot
intense fight and it's a decisive one we
will come straight back to it but there
is also big action in the other game
alireza ferruja has to win on demand to
force an Armageddon and it does look
like has he created chances because he
is up a pawn
it's up to one point it might well be
two there we go Tanya two pawns up for
black and you might argue that there are
dark squared holes around the black king
but it's actually the white king that
might feel the heat the black Bishop's
so powerful so potent hitting the G2
square and it feels like Dimitri here
he's lost control I don't see any
threats against the black king that
can't easily be parried and if that
black Rook ever gets down to the second
rank to D2 which is going to be game
over do we think any chances here for
white
slightly slightly especially because
time's getting low as we saw even with
the game where alireza was winning the
Army he just got a long time in that
game it was a heartbreaker game where he
had to find Bishop D6 but he got a very
long time spent that seven and a half
minute think there and got in trouble
and lost the game there so it is very
possible for things to happen here
especially as we mentioned the dark
squares are weak right so we can
obviously poke some holes eventually if
we're able to cover G2 Queen H4 could be
an idea and then maybe try to make the
dark square is obviously weaker maybe
even Stack The Exchange put a knight on
e4 and try to get a knight to F6 many
possibilities here for both sides but
it's not over yet
Queenie do you played and the one move
that white cannot make is Rook 2 F2 that
would walk into a back rack made you
have to count on these threats for black
the G2 Pawn is a soft spot but also back
rank weaknesses so Dimitri kolars is in
trouble currently
yep he is in trouble he's just trying to
initiate this kind of Perpetual attack
against the black queen but the black
queen will eventually find a safe Square
um there we go pretty safe can't be
attacked or harassed anymore if you hit
her with the white Rook the black queen
is happy to uh capture that piece and
again what do you do with white next
you're a bit tied up the White Queen is
purely passive right now defending G2
black has huge threats Rook D3 coming
just push the black a pawn looks uh
looks almost over to me yeah white is so
hamstrung by the fact that he's got to
keep G2 protected he's got to keep the
back ring protected and he doesn't have
access to the E4 Square because the
Knight really wants to be on F6 that's
the prime real estate can't get there
it'll be snapped off the board looks
like Ollie Rose has got this packed up
wrapped up we're going to an Armageddon
here barring a miracle oh wow I love it
and as we saw in our feature chat about
Shiba there that how did alireza manage
to get this after the opening that we
saw the Knight dance Knight F6 98 986
well desperate times calling for
desperate measures and it looks like it
managed to confuse uh Dimitri and
alireza in a driver seat right now
putting pressure on that G2 Pawn the a
pawn has a clear path down the road uh
we will keep an eye out on this one but
it is likely to head into an Armageddon
let's check back with the action on the
Hikaru board and Hikaru down in exchange
when we left it last continues to be so
but the pieces still really active but
with the Queens off the board has the
danger minimized for Jordan
wow I'm trying to do a quick uh Scout
here of the position it feels like white
is survived the worst but can white be
better potentially now there's no Rooks
on the board for black White's Rook
could be the key piece you are blundered
horribly a couple of moves ago he gave
up a Pawn on the king side and with that
his whole position started to crumbly he
was forced to exchange a pair of Rooks
which always favors the side that's up
in exchange because the minor pieces now
have to basically keep White's crazy
Rook at Bay and they can shuttle
trampoline from one side of the board to
the other and attack Black's pawns I
think the likeliest outcome is a draw
but if white coordinates is tandem well
get ready
yep I fully agree and maybe Daniel just
while these players think uh just a
quick recap of that blunder black here
in full charge black Hikaru was almost
winning actually brought his Rook across
simply forgetting that Rook takes Pawn
One upon this would have walked into a
nasty nightfork and now the momentum has
changed it's all about Jordan and can he
bring this King into the game it looks
like maybe this King can start creeping
forward at some point the White Knight
also trying to get in with a nasty check
I think white is a big favorite in this
end game it feels like Hikaru is playing
for a draw at best
wow yeah absolutely practical chances uh
for sure I mean white definitely has the
exchange here but of course we have seen
things go wrong and as time gets lower
things do go wrong we do have a tricky
night for black don't blunder a fork
that one's gonna hurt but at the end of
the day here I mean we do have to make
sure that we uh you know make the best
of our position 95 I actually like maybe
is he gonna take on C6 that might be and
then maybe play Rook D4 though E3 oh my
goodness it gets rid of the pawn I think
this is going to be a draw oh the
evaluation Bob reacting hugely though
maybe not
maybe the Black Knight will get caught
on a bad circuit white still will be
left with one remaining Pawn maybe that
white a pawn will be the MVP and uh
promote long term that's such a natural
move King to D4 but we see that it's a
mistake as the eval bar creeps right
back up King D6 now hitting that Knight
and perhaps if you trade on C6 black
wants to recapture with the King but I
would be worried with that Knight on G2
that black knight will there be a way
home that's the big question and Jordan
yes he does want to eliminate that black
Bishop which holds everything together
but
two versus one on the queen side Black's
G Pawn will fall let's forget about that
one I don't think it's enough to win no
yeah are we having an armaget and then
this one yes oh wow yes by Daniel James
yes oh David here yes
potentially two Army Gardens if this one
ends in a draw and alireza wins his
match we're in for more exciting chess
while King D6 has been played and
players playing on seconds so Jordan
decides to keep the tension on the board
the minor pieces remain he wants to come
in with the rookies he's still trying to
win he's also trying to trap that Knight
on G2 man
oh 18 seconds for as well drops
his Bishop back to EA maybe armor
getting in this position
wow okay
this feels loose
the pawn started falling was he holding
how is he holding he's so badly
coordinated as well oh he's gonna lose
his Knight or is he or no
okay is that light trapped if you just
take that black Bishop of
feels like there's something in the air
the evaluation bar confirms it I think
we need a helping hand what does
stockfish say is there it's not there
it's not this it's not that how the
Black Knight gets out
yeah be careful big thread on the board
King C5 maybe hide away
yeah this one should be a draw now
however still hard though A4 A5 I mean
man
yeah this Black Knight need to get it
back in the game and uh there was a move
where uh Jordan was winning it was
difficult though so we might uh have to
backtrack on that one later but still
under 20 seconds now for Hikaru let's
stick with this current position can he
get his Knight back in the game can he
liquidate here
so close he's on the brink
Knight attacking the white Rook yeah
yeah
like before maybe a threat oh now you
let the white king in this feels yeah
that feels wrong intuitive definitely
feels wrong we have holes in a position
we can play this almost forever as long
as we don't blunder a uh Fork here
obviously check and moving fast
car is holding I mean his pawns are so
well defended by the minor pieces Jordan
has to find some geometry here yeah that
somehow knocks Black's pieces off to
awkward squares and it's really hard to
do with no time
yeah really good player I've got to say
by Nakamura in the last few moves
defending when uh any slip would cost in
the game but now he drops back with his
King maybe the white Rook has to go
around the other way
and okay just cut off that black key and
just put the Rook on d8
don't Mouse slip and don't miss a fork
those are two big gifts especially
wow so tense right I mean you just play
Forever and hope for a blunder that's
how these positions are
when's the 50 move rule
Are We There Yet 95 maybe you know
that's the kind of trick or you have to
put on the board it's a milk clock time
off a car's clock but Jordan keeps
trying to find new avenues for his night
but his rook's getting kicked away
Hikaru is still defending everything so
far black king can start heading back
soon
wow look at Yvonne bar creep up like
that that comes again Knight A5 and King
B6 oh yeah you're right Knight E5 there
it is horn is dropping 17 seconds this
is literally a 30 second game but under
30 seconds obviously
how do you hold things together maybe
you can't that poor is threatened Now
quickly be fine okay seven he's losing
oh my goodness
oh you can see the anger you can see the
anger there look F6 would have been very
strong as well but this is just looks
like game over
black king and huge huge trouble and the
remaining black pawn falling now check
tough just take it House of Cards
now it should be simple just push that
white a pawn forward and Hikaru crash
into defeat on day one they call me
Michael Jordan not over yet it's easy to
wander a fork and if you trade the
knights prematurely there's some crazy
theoretical positions here that could be
dropped of course it's totally winning
I've just seen too many Hikaru games oh
I understandable I love what Jordan's
done though he's kept his King and Rook
as far away as possible literally as far
away apart as possible and uh therefore
no Forks now just don't be careful be
careful wow I think this is the first
time that we may see ikaru knocked out I
mean we was actually going to be with
fedes before for the save was very close
but he was able to win that match a good
thing it's a double eliminate
another
another lose at this match he will go
down to the elimination bracket and in
fact he has gone down to the elimination
bracket Jordan van Forest takes it with
some brilliant technique in the end what
a match this has been and Jordan
we should mention Hikaru hasn't actually
clicked the resign Button he's just left
oh he just walks still ticking down
six
six he's just left it
Jordan Juan forest does take the match
after that Victory wow what a game what
a performance not just the score line
but also the way Jordan did it I was
unbelievable the amount of times that he
put for he did what I normally does I
mean that seemed to be in the bag for
Nakamura once he got rid of that
kingside pawn I mean his pawns were
defended somehow Jordan with the
gymnastics where this piece has got his
King through got his night through
didn't blunder a fork kept his composure
really an amazing day in Jordan's chess
career on an amazing day it's not easy
to take down Hikaru Nakamura in the
match format David what made it happen
take us through the big moment well it
was a bit of a roller coaster up and
down game this one between Jordan van
Forrest and hikaranakamura but I think
it was decided in this one move Hikaru
had done everything right he'd
negotiated navigated his way through
complicated Waters and it was just here
where black has a huge advantage that he
slipped up black for example could have
pushed his Pawn forward B5 B4 this lone
white Pawn is an easy target and
actually Black's Knight dominates the
whole board black has a decisive
Advantage but Rook to F5 clumsy Square
allowing Rook takes pawn and suddenly
the game was up for grabs and we saw a
few moves later white was able to trade
off these two Rooks and with his extra
Rook was able to win the game
what an amazing day of Chess it's been
so many twists and turns and let's take
a look at our score line and where we
stand well we will have one Armageddon
alireza feruja doing what needed to be
done winning that game with black in
that fourth round that matches level we
will have the bids and we will see what
happens in that big matchup with of
course the big upset has to be Jordan
man first taking down Hikaru Nakamura
while Fabiano caruana and not the back
of dosatro made it look easy wrapping up
their match in just three games I have
to ask you guys
alireza Dimitri we got an Armageddon in
that one that's gonna be fun Ollie Rez
has got to be feeling really good right
now let me not you cannot emphasize how
hard it is to win with black on demand
against an elephant he played Knight G8
Dimitri he's going to be kicking himself
right now he was that close to scoring
the second crazy upset but he's got to
push all that aside we're gonna we're
gonna have an Armageddon this is gonna
be awesome it's gonna be super awesome
and the one player who's got to be
feeling really awesome is Jordan man
Forest what a win when you take down a
player like Hikaru Nakamura that's a
huge confidence boost David yeah no
matter how you play as long as you get
the win as long as you get the result
especially against the giant of the game
like Nakamura you're going to be on top
of the world so uh Jordan it was a bit
of a bonus that he played well all day
he was able to hang with uh Nakamura and
just when he got his moment he seized it
uh yeah he's gonna be one to watch for
the rest of the tournament now Riding
High he wouldn't run for it
this is amazing stuff definitely Riding
High and we're gonna take this moment to
go into a shot twitch break don't go
anywhere
[Music]
on Saturday May 27th your favorite
streamers will battle it out in a tour
bullet arena with 2500 on the line it's
going to be fast it's going to be fun
and it's going to be crazy use the
command brawl in chat for all the
details
welcome back everyone it's been a
fantastic day of Chess and we've got
more news coming in from Simon Simon
what's going on
yeah hi there so we got lots of updates
going on in division two and three and
uh we can bring up some graphics very
shortly to have a look at what's
actually happened there
um so let's start with division two and
have a look at the winners there and I
think a big shock at the top there
Dmitry adri Aiken who must have been one
of the favorites has lost that one so
that is a a big shock and just going
down the list we see a favorite of Spain
David Anton has gone through uh Carol uh
alexenko also going through so uh it's
really heating up there remember it is
double elimination in all these
divisions so it doesn't mean they are
out and maybe now we could have a look
at division three as well and uh
division three we've had even more games
more players and uh more games going on
and here's the first page and pick your
favorite player we see another Norwegian
I am tarry has managed to win that first
game of the data been eating renito
Terry and the second page there well
looking at names you Yang Yi a bit of a
legend of the game and one name I would
like to mention is valiaco pons there
because he is dings one of ding's
favorite players the new world champion
went asked to his favorite players were
it was Valley Echo and Valley Echoes as
far down as division three which is a
bit shocking really you know if he's
ding's favorite player should at least
be in division two but maybe he'll get
there very soon and dare I say another
legend of the game there
gattacamski and we know why he's a
legend don't we and the last page for
the winners this is the next round
Valley Echo beating gatakowski there
Vincent Kmart is at the moment one all
against Igor lysi uh Vincent won his
first match and Sam Savion is also
having a good time of it so far so
there's lots of stuff happening there's
so many games and the last page here oh
it goes on and on doesn't it whoa
keeping me on my feet and we have lots
of interesting results and uh renetto
Terry may be a bit of a shock against
one of um India's strongest players well
uh nowadays they've got so many strong
players there and you have some of the
strong Germans Alexander dongchenko
winning a good match here bad day for
Andrew Tang we might see him on the
bullet Arena later somewhere but lots of
results going on everywhere there
um so yeah exciting stuff I mean there's
so much chess going on that you can pick
from so where yeah division one is good
but some of the names there they were
fantastic as well weren't they so uh too
much chess to follow even really
um great stuff but yeah what about that
Hikaru match that was obviously the
match of the day so yeah yeah just
amazing stuff and some really big names
there Simon Hari Krishna in the mix the
famous fun Legend garakamski as you were
talking about and I'll just say it does
this just show the reflection is this
just a reflection of the strength of the
just get Gap the kind of names that we
saw down in division three it's amazing
yeah is yeah I mean there's there's just
so many there's such strength going
through the divisions there it's not
just division one so we have that
division two the division three and
they're all fighting for a place in this
first division because that's where you
get all their all the glory isn't it
really so uh who will be there we'll
have to wait and see there's plenty more
days to come and speaking of Glory the
one player who did get that side today
has to be yard and Van Forest he is a
last minute replacement here at the
chess get cup division one and he digs
down and garonakamura what do you think
of that uh yeah I mean that was just
fantastic I mean Jordan's a great player
he's one awaken Z which is called The
Wimbledon of Chess before and I kind of
like how Hikaru uh resigned that game he
did I think it's a Brandenburg is
something like that this is famous
player in the Hastings tournament I
think it was in 1898 who lost I think to
steinus and uh this this while he lost
he actually just he had an hour and a
half on his clock and he just left the
building so it's like uh that that
that's that's a statement that is it's
like I'm not going to resign I'm just
going to leave the building but uh
heartbreaking for Hikaru but we've got
to give Jordan so much credit there
because it was his great chess that won
the match
at the very end Eric I literally left
the chat but of course he does have one
more life left at the chess kitka and
you can never rule him out and action
also continues with alireza and Dimitri
Kola is going into Armageddon and we do
have the bids let's reveal the
Armageddon bids and there they're in WoW
alireza ferrugia winning the bid as he
bit for 8 minutes and 20 seconds Dimitri
colas nine minutes and 29 seconds which
means that if alireza does pick the
black pieces the metric will start with
15 minutes on the clock what are you
expecting well Ali Reza go for the black
pieces here I think he will especially
given his success in the previous game
he had the lower bid I think he's gonna
go with black he seemed a lot happier in
that photo than Dimitri does he's a lot
happier to be in the Armageddon than uh
Demetrius we are getting an update that
indeed has
chosen the black pieces which means that
Dimitri will start with 15 minutes on
the clock 8 minutes and 28 seconds but
irisa does have to draw odds Dimitri has
to win to take the match and guys I have
to ask you eight and a half minutes
almost eight and a half minutes it's not
too low by alireza how low can you go
that's the question and eight for me
would be uh Unthinkable but ferrugia is
super fast he's super good at
calculation and he's riding on a high he
just won with black so with the draw in
hand it feels like eight should be
enough absolutely I think eight is an
eighth enough especially he's very
prepared I mean he uses he knows really
almost every opening as it is he's been
2800 before so really I think having
that black I'm always thinking black
every time in Armageddon because I have
the two options I either win I win I
draw I win right so always gonna take
that yeah but the kind of chest that
we've been seeing by these two I don't
think we've seen a single draw in their
games it's been uh it's been four
decisive results uh be shocked if we saw
a draw in the Armageddon eight and a
half minutes eight minutes 28 seconds
for alireza farusha but he's such a
beast in those time scrambles we've seen
him play online we've seen him play
online all those 30-second uh time
scrambles will come in handy because in
Armageddon there is no increment there's
no time added per move Tanya so it's a
completely different game flagging is
very much on the table if you're Dimitri
callers gotta get those bullet skills
out dust them off and gotta show them
this game let's go yeah on the menu and
it's highly recommended in the
Armageddon Dimitri Cola starts with the
white pieces but he has to win on demand
he will have 15 minutes on the clock uh
David what is your prediction what's the
strategy with Whitetail to try and flag
your opponent how do you do that good
question uh Tanya it's the Eternal
dilemma do you go very direct to try to
knock your opponent out immediately and
I hope the fact that they don't have any
time kind of backfires on them they
can't kind of calculate their way
through the chaos or do you just keep
the tension prolong the game as long as
possible and at the right moment speed
up and talking of speed up they have
sped off and uh okay the Berlin Rock
Solid from uh
no Berlin Jones
I assume he's going to say auntie Berlin
but no okay he castles and what is he
gonna go for the end game no he goes for
rookie one solid stuff I'm surprised
I've got to say Daniel James I don't
like it don't like it either I mean of
course it's very solid and it's a great
reputation from the black side with this
opening here of course white still has
very solid play but hey I think we
needed more something a little bit more
ambitious he still can go very ambitious
here with some maybe some different move
orders here but I mean this stuff's
already played out many different ways
it's probably uh gonna be difficult for
white for sure yeah very forcing lines
uh I was saying the second kind of
approach would have been just keep
pieces on the board and try to flag your
opponent later when given the
opportunity the problem is here pieces
will fly off the board and unless you
gain an objective Advantage the clock is
unlikely unlikely to play a factor
um yeah I'm really really surprised I'm
also curious what he has in store
Dimitri he would have had these things
on his mind so he must have a specific
idea up his sleeve but
yeah ferocious come prepared yeah with a
very smart choice in the opening going
for the Berlin and now Dimitri has to
try to keep all the pieces on the board
keep the critical decisions for when
alireza's clock is really down on the
minutes Bishop C5 played looking for
activity along that diagonal some
threats some tactical ideas there Bishop
F2 in the air you want to pick up that
pawn once the king comes to F2 you can
give a check on F6 win that Rook well
Dimitri of course spots it blocks it
with the move Bishop E3 but this is
going to be difficult to try to get
something out of with white out of the
opening yeah
yeah simple as that it's difficult an
agreement here we all agree and Black's
main move I've had this position
actually myself okay I was gonna say
Black's main move was actually to push
the d-pawn forward attack that white
rook in the center but uh still very
solid and uh okay now he's just gonna
bring his Black Knight out bring the
black Bishop Alton unless Dimitri can
make use of his small space advantage
we will see an equal position okay this
one's still life left though yeah
there's some Lively but I mean I do find
that blacks just are always fine in
these lines we've traded some pieces I
got the same as you I mean I said okay
you have the pawn on D5 but actually I
mean it's not that strong because you
are only defending it with the Knight
here and of course I don't have like
many moves for white to actually try to
create some things I'm just trying to
wait for you to make something wrong and
do something wrong black can play Bishop
F5 Queen D7 move the other Rook to E8
and then trade everything off and like
we can shake hands and I'm I'm gonna
Advance right so it's very difficult for
white here to really create some chances
here he plays Queen D4 maybe some Rook
G3 Bishop G3 stuff you gotta go for it
yeah but the black Bishop okay I was
gonna say maybe comes out to F5 hits the
undefended C2 Pawn uh very kind of
modest play here from farusha uh White
Spirits have doubled up yeah but there's
this there's a very annoying idea Rook
takes E3 and then Queen f8 and rookie
eight and if but the problem is the A7
Pawn hangs and I know it's too early to
talk about flagging and strat's like of
course Daniel nerdis he's talking about
flagging rather than discussing the
position he's looking at the clock but
these types of positions they lend
themselves to very long end games and
you should not be shy if you're Dimitri
you can go rook in three versus rook in
three and alireza has a minute to your
seven you know you go for it
yeah uh Daniel what would you be your
strategy here in terms of playing on the
clock obviously rooken three versus rook
and three that's kind of further down
yeah do you do you keep the tension do
you just do you go for some tactics just
to force your opponent to tank a bit
yeah you asked some questions but
without sacrificing objectivity so
Bishop D3 is a move that I would
consider here you make these slow
undefined moves to force your opponent
into making a bunch of decisions exactly
what Dimitri is doing A4 is a nice
Russian Schoolboy move just grab some
space push that pawn up non-committal
you want to keep this non-committal
position as long as possible A5 or
Bishop D3 would be consistent with this
strategy
yeah send me some questions the black B7
Pawn is backward now it could be a
target for the White Queen a bit later
on end games if it's the right kind of
configuration of minor pieces not
necessarily safe for black anymore
I'm liking the way this is going and
also ferrugia he spent over two minutes
from starting this game we're at move 19
now
you would have wanted to be a bit
quicker if you were him to be honest no
difficult decisions so far but he has
spent a significant amount of his uh
allotted time under six minutes now
because we have this space now it
definitely waits for a choice I mean we
have space space is a huge Advantage so
having a lot of space I mean black just
seemed like we could trade more pieces
here but why I got this space What work
is active here you have to be careful
when we have to use our time wisely here
then B4 more space D6 is kind of weak so
maybe we play this on as much as we can
B6 is weak now Bishop D3 is probably a
possibility you may have some attacking
chances so definitely I kind of like
white here a black side is clear right
he wants to get rid of all the Rook so
he's already gotten rid of one but
rookie 8 is to follow to try to
liquidate the position as much as
possible Dimitri still got more than
half the amount of time he's up by
almost seven minutes on the clock Queen
D7 Rook here is a track how does white
keep it going how does white keep the
pressure you don't want to trade that
last uh those last pair of Rooks
um you wouldn't love to but giving away
the e-files also really committal Rook
G3 super tempting for especially for a
lot of newer players but black and Slide
the king over or play Knight F6 to H5
and start harassing that rook and you
don't want that Rook to meet the fate of
hikaru's Rook on G4 here it will be a
white Rook on G4 and it's still under a
lot of fire so decisions to be made for
Dimitri but even with the Rooks off the
board he retains a slight pole yeah for
example if you just move your Bishop
forward uh if the Rooks do disappear
even if the Queens disappear long term
here I don't know if black can take with
the queen maybe you can just because uh
this Pawn can't be captured there's a
nasty check but even if the Queens come
off this Pawn long term is going to be a
big weakness long term as well white has
the opportunity to potentially create a
passport on the side of the board
I like White's position uh I gotta admit
even in an end game and uh he's going
for that second approach not going for
any attack he's getting ready once the
White Queen moves later on to plant his
Knight in the center on a nice outpost
on D4 so very much for the long game
here from Dimitri Collins and will it
pay off that's the big question still
six minutes ahead on the clock yeah and
a lovely question for Dmitry is what
does he do about this Rook trade will he
try to avoid it right now or will he go
for a rookie eight ideas allow the Rooks
to be traded off the board it is a big
moment which will also show us exactly
how he's feeling about the position what
are you expecting the rook's on or off I
think he's going to keep them on uh well
I think he's going to keep his work on
E3 and consider him of like Knight F4 or
take on E8 I think he doesn't mind The
Rook trade as David indicated that pawn
majority on the queen size possibility
of C4 and B5 I'm licking my chops
thinking about black facing that with
five minutes on the clock Rook D3 there
is a case to be made for that hitting
the D6 Pawn there's a lot of logistical
problems Bishop B5 giving up the e-file
tactics with Bishop C6 takes G2 2
overloaded Bishop on F1 I would steer
clear of that and I would uh I wouldn't
mind getting the Rooks off the board
yeah I think he might capture this black
Rook because I think the Black Knight
will be forced to retreat so it does
give you a move or two uh to kind of get
organized as white but equally you could
wait and trade on your terms uh say to
fruition okay you spend the move taking
the Rooks off the board there we go
there it is yeah the Black Knight at
least passive for a move or two and uh
Dimitri stepping forward Daniel's plan
of C4 B5 very much in the air uh also
watch out for that white knight going to
H5 just in case uh keeping Black's
pieces honest
yeah I would choose white here every
time but winning advantage
probably not with best play Black still
forced to defend and it's not a farusha
type of position he doesn't necessarily
well actually nobody likes defending
slightly passive uh positions where it's
just two results playing for the draw uh
at the very best but uh yeah he does
tend to feel a bit uncomfortable in
situations like this one yeah the more
pieces that come off I mean it does look
better and they see for farouza here we
do have the three versus two on the
queen side which is obviously in the
in-game so they always tell you that
that is great you do want to have the
queen side majority when it comes to the
end games I mean but why is for choice
right we got Queen B6 C4 B5 at some
point 985 also just throwing it in there
just to throw it in there make some
weaknesses around the king there right
we have options and possibilities which
gives us uh you know lots of good
chances for counter play and also maybe
just chances for some type of initiative
and having farrugia low on time with no
increment here as well wow otherwise
that strategy looks super clear he's
just going for B straight after peace
trade that Knight on C7 is looking to
head to that E6 Square hopefully get
those Knights off the board even if you
go Knight H5 hitting that G7 Pawn 96 is
the idea and your uh your move on the
board Daniel C4 always eyeing that B5
push but that's Square currently is
overprotected by black Black's got three
pieces defending that B5 advance and
that's going to be key to make sure that
never happens this is very mature Chess
By callers not afraid of 96 but I was
going to point this out Tanya D5 is a
big move I think that was missed by
Dimitri who probably devoted his
attention to 96 which would have been
bad and he reacts quickly with that H5
for Russia he can't afford to miss a
second made in one sorry that was below
the belt there's also tactics 96
for again threatening Knight F6 David oh
he's walking on hot coals is alireza but
are these more than just one getting off
the board get him off the board Bishop
Zuma is trapped and suddenly watch out
yeah oh my queen I can't believe it just
two moves ago he had three pieces
defending it and now the a pawn is
advancing marching down the board
alireza is at the brink of defeat right
now how do you spot stop the a pawn
I'm not sure you do if you move your
Bishop back for example where'd you go
then suddenly just Pawn takes Pawn a
pawn shops off oh gosh you had to play
King h8 and I think he was actually okay
he completely forgot about White's main
idea which was B5 another blunder yeah
another blunder and it's natural it's
easy to blunder when you only have four
minutes on your clock he has to deal
with the ruins of this position maybe
the best is just take and drop back and
hope that you can somehow stop this Pawn
but I don't think you will long term it
feels like this is a potential killer
and uh simple play for white as well
that's the problem for ferrugia right
now over five minutes down and with a
terrible position that's tough and they
say they to play for a draw you have to
play for a win right so it didn't seem
like black really ever tried to just do
anything besides trade pieces which
seemed like he was trying to play Four
draw there which is easier said than
done right now obviously we have the
trade here you play A6 we take take the
bishop can go back to C6 and it's not
over yet but you are definitely I mean
with engine's like yo this is over start
a new game look at the bar but it is uh
it's a practical chance as a human here
and of course he doesn't know A6 wasn't
even a move that's crazy to even say
that I don't know what to me was but of
course it's still chances here for black
it's far from over yeah I think we would
have all play day six but then the
engine was like no no no why Rush uh so
maybe the White Queen could have
repositioned herself but this looks very
very natural all right uh surely there's
a way to kind of combine threats against
the black king with uh kind of
deflection tactics uh pushing that white
people and even funnier the thing is
it's so easy to sack other people's
pieces now it takes you something does
not work it's very tempting 927 97 Queen
C8 but black and simply blocked that
with his Queen so you don't want again
you don't want to walk into the Trap of
writing a tactics book here you want to
win in more straightforward fashion I'd
consider a slow move David like Bishop
F1 to D3 involving everyone in the party
queen G4 can also drop back to G3
marking a path to B8 so one of those
slow moves to keep the tension also
you're keeping an eye on Black's clock
because that could decide the game as
well F4 is a risky move opens his own
King up yeah suddenly this white king
vulnerable to checks on the diagonal I
don't like it to be honest I'm very bad
actually my biggest weakness in chess is
kind of spotting the moment to push
these pawns forward just because I'm so
kind of concerned and obsessed with King
safety is this a good moment evaluation
Bar says yes it's okay but not the best
and suddenly look at what fridge is
doing he's keeping an eye on this white
king I'm assuming he's going to drop his
Queen back now and White's gonna have to
weaken himself even further if he ever
wants to step forward I really really
don't like it and okay forage is
actually going in a different angle
Queen to D4 pinning the pawn in this
Direction Still white Advantage you've
got to say but black with some chances
of uh counter-attack later on absolutely
here this is why to move okay so I play
Queen G3 okay well we'll see maybe F5
still on tap here F5 Queen B8 pushing at
five we're live at five and we live
absolutely F5 also F6 possibilities too
as well but Queen ba A7 looks really
good there
uh yikes for ferusal there is just
moving a little too fast obviously he
had to and quickly being down on time no
increment but also uh not not playing
for I think more ambition just playing a
little bit more ambitious playing for
the win you wouldn't play for a draw you
play for a win right and I think a lot
he kind of played for a draw here Queen
B8 we're doing great A7 we in heaven
come on bro all right that's my brother
here right now I'm learning from the
basketball for Russia he is not going
gentle into that good night at all right
hitting the white Bishop now do you
ignore that threat do you kind of motor
on forward push the F Pawn forward
absolutely let's go it's the only thing
twice about it too tempting itchy
fingers just push forward
yeah the option is moving the white
Bishop which also looks tempting I've
got to say but uh okay he chooses the
latter option
evaluation bar approves two and a half
minutes still so much tension so many
pitfalls to negotiate later okay seven
yeah now because the bishop on C6 also
holds the promotion Square so you don't
have these deflection ideas where you
promote
because Black's Bishop also holds the
promotion Square okay question is F5
completely crazy here no looks nice
and okay so many reading ideas engine
suggests three winning moves then
probably more but all of them are moving
the white lights go ahead Bishop just
get out of the way get out Dodge and
actually black is a bit stuck as well
Black's Queen has to stay on the
diagonal protecting her King side uh
protecting the G7 Pawn then wow you can
even let your Pawn drop oh that's hard
though David and if you move the bishop
away from the B1 H7 diagonal Knight E4
is a very nasty move that's little bone
and White's throat there you don't want
the Queen off the G file so this is a
huge moment I think F5 we're attempting
Knight takes D3 though and if you play
F6 black plays G6 and black might be
holding on there
or 25
wins you might have to take that Knight
back on D3 but then you've got to check
it out
so attempting but I love it F5 on the
board and Ali Reza well it's not the
best move but you have to say this is
the most empty move why does it take
back on D3 yes that's the only chance
but objectively this might be close to a
draw but yeah the queen now is perfectly
centralized for black and
key is this position I don't think black
needs to take that's the key because
then the white king comes in you just
support your queen
oh my goodness if you take then Black's
pawns are running it's Daniel the d-pawn
that's gonna win this
oh my gosh wow
um let's not forget that Dimitri has to
win the game a draw would mean that
alireza verusa takes the match fi was a
tempting option but it was incorrect and
now alireza slows down he's a minute and
a half on the clocks Charlie the clock
yeah Charlie the clock is in play right
now there's no increment for the players
he can't give a check on E5 I'm
surprised at how much time he's taking
right now
men he knows that if he finds the right
two or three moves he can hold a very
simple position even with 45 seconds
allowing what queen G3 you have lost it
what's the win though I think it just
might be Queen G3 and there are so many
Avenues and David that's not a mouse
slip that's not a mouse lip it also
makes almost no sense it just feels like
Panic from farusha Queen G3 is one
winning move because Queen E3 just
coming in any angles but as Daniel says
Quincy through sled the queen back which
came from block any checks keep the
white king safe and uh many many angles
you can infiltrate black position he
finds it oh man I'm literally baffled by
that one you know what's funny we I felt
weird because he was shaking his head
before he played King of Faith like he
just was lost but I mean queen E5 was
just a start he put the queen
centralized as the Queen James Queen E5
I'm sure he found that but F6 could be a
move that he missed and not Queen G7
in yeah
might be mate King there Queen check
King Air check there
must be a Checkmate right I think F6
might be made but that has to be fully
calculated F6 GF and then Queen D6
followed by Knight takes F6 and back to
H5 I think that's mate wow you can give
a check first on D6 maybe and okay he
goes for the line the line you mentioned
Daniel there that's a great call
and gf6 would be game over as you
mentioned that's a myth with a check on
D6 maybe you've got to go King to G8 the
other side then whatever he does he has
to do it now it's under a minute and you
have no increment 50 seconds
yeah at this point with the clock even
if he survives this attack
even if he had 10 minutes on the clock
it's hard to survive this game now we've
actually said this several times today
Queen and Knight versus queen of Bishop
attacking combo if you get the attack on
the front foot with with the queen and
Knight your opponent's pieces can't
fight back and this has got to be made
surely Queen D6 you go in
oh my gosh even Queen G7 is winning you
can just take the F Pawn oh yeah it
doesn't even matter what you do that's
true as long as you don't allow
Perpetual like G4 Queen A2 check would
be the literally the only way to mess
this one up yeah yeah cool that's what
I'd probably do
Carlos has been so professional we've
got to say he spent his time so wisely
he's still got almost five minutes in
the bank and he's investing it now just
spend two three minutes calculate your
way to Victory and
now nothing for us you can do 30 seconds
it's just a bit of disaster the last few
moves unfortunately an amazing clock
management by ecologies as well to just
keep four minutes on the clock attacking
possibilities in a Berlin not an easy
task at all he slows down he's trying to
calculate his way is there a direct part
can he go for Queen dear Queen Effie he
loves Queen beer but I think Queen oh I
saw this too but it's just he just
repeats you go King G8 and you have to
do it anyway you have to go for the same
lines so professional he takes even one
second off for Rooster's clock is worth
its weight in gold right
wow that was sick though Daniel that was
a very smart I mean because he's low
he's low on time so what he did there
was repeat that was sick Queen G7 easy
clap
yeah yeah or less
93.6 is forced mate oh wow he's spotted
it and you have to take on F6 because
Queen G7 check mate is the threat and
here we go Knight in not enough
he takes H6 Unstoppable mate wow and
there's not a single check on white
right now that Queen on A6 isn't coming
into the game at all Queen 86 just
blocks any path he goes with Queen F6
also good enough King f8 runs into Queen
d8 Bishop
is made in one and you can see it on
Dimitris he knows he's done it he was
the underdog in this match but he's
clearly been the better player today and
Dimitri colors takes it in the Army
Garden he had to win with the white
pieces and that's exactly what he's done
what an Armageddon that was and David
Dimitri always had it under control yeah
to me entry had it under control a
really good game in the end we
questioned his opening choice but
actually it turned out to be inspired
for Russia never had enough time to
really uh kind of fight back and keep
things under control and it was here
that uh black had the only chance really
of the later stages of the game here for
Asia panicking on the clock played King
f8 a bit of a nothing move losing time
and giving white sufficient time to uh
go on the attack once more it was
actually dropping back with the black
queen that would have saved him Queen to
E5 check centralization over everything
here Coe and after Queen G3 F6 locking
down the position and actually white
struggles purely because of this pin any
end game is savable for black and as we
saw after Queen G3 it was a very quick
checkmating attack starting with F6
really nice stuff from Dimitri colors
it's been a tough day for alireza we
also saw him struggle a lot in the air
things Masters he's down to the
elimination bracket he's got only one
alive left now here at the chess gate
cup he's gotta find his rhythm today
looked extremely shaky and the
Armageddon was a brilliant play there by
Dimitri let's take a look at our
final score line for the day and we see
Hikaru Nakamura goes down to Jordan van
Forrest alireza fuchsia also finds
himself in elimination bracket and we've
got not a bag of dosatrov and Fabiano
caruana the two favorites who did go
through and they do stay in the Winner's
bracket what a day of Chess it's been
and of course with the double
elimination we will still have action
from the players who did Lewis today
what was the highlight for you Daniel
first of all the Highlight was just
being here and covering day one this was
amazing and uh live up lived up to its
expectations obviously Jordan van Forest
playing such incredible inspired chess
and Dimitri kolars demonstrating such
Poise after losing game one that final
stretch of the Armageddon that belongs
in a textbook and the way that he
handled his clock the two underdogs
today Tanya they performed but the
silver lining for the top guys it's
double elimination you can't say that
enough times an angry car Nakamura
tomorrow steer clear yeah
it's gonna be a big day of Chess as
action will indeed continue and as you
mentioned Daniel the double elimination
means that indeed we will see the
players back of fighting in their final
life one more strike and they're out but
right now the player who is celebrating
is Dimitri colors after his Armageddon
win against
congratulations Dimitri
thank you yeah what a tremendous
exciting match it was to watch just an
absolute delight and I want to ask you
uh this is your debut in division one
you take down the world number four sum
up this roller coaster of a day that you
had
it was even more exciting to play than
than to watch probably
um yeah I feel like I feel like I should
have lost the match probably but I made
so many mistakes I mean the first game I
just Blended and I can't even remember
the games but yeah summer probably had
enough day but okay I also found some
practical chances I think sometimes but
yeah the last game I mean the last game
the first game was
yes also not great I thought that was
probably it but but then he was bidding
so low in the Armageddon I didn't didn't
expect eight minutes uh I don't know
maybe maybe just as normal I don't have
any experience with this but uh yeah so
this is not much
and somehow I got good chances in the
game
and yeah worked out
of the five games that you played today
Dimitri you won three all of them were
decisive it was an amazing match to
watch and you mentioned the Armageddon
that you thought that Ali Reza bid
perhaps a little bit too low when he
played the Berlin what was your thought
and what was your Approach at that
moment
yeah I had prepared this a bit for
before the match because I mean it makes
sense you could play the Berlin I was
expecting a Petrov of course because he
played it earlier it was a solid
um but yeah I just I just played what I
prepared and and thought I was a bit
surprised by his line was Knight E8
instead of Rocky 8 yeah I mean this is
at least
slightly more pleasant to play maybe
when I get D5 yeah but yeah
I don't know
um also the position is uh not so
difficult to play how many pieces on the
board I thought probably I won't get
many chances but maybe I can flag him in
the end or something but yeah some some
of the game went well
an amazing how to ask you as your debut
in
in what's your ambition in this
tournament and just your thoughts on the
chesskit gap
yeah I didn't didn't have any ambition
I thought I'd be here for today's and
then
start watching but
now now I have to play a bit longer I
also have to switch some some plans now
I think but uh yeah it's just exciting
to play
completely new for me normally I don't
get
this like these opponents not sure who
Am I who I'm playing tomorrow but
uh yeah I still can't speak apparently
but yeah
um and do you think that's the special
part of this year's championship store
the format with the planes it gives the
opportunity for strong Grandmasters like
yourself to compete against the world's
best
yeah this is something very interesting
about it yeah I mean I'm not the only
one who qualified from this rating range
yeah I think that's very interesting to
have the top players against them
like lower rated ones
and yeah apparently it's it can also be
exciting yeah so I probably I won't have
a chance today but yeah somewhere ahead
well Dimitri it was an amazing start by
you and a super fun match to watch for
all of us here doing commentary as well
as for the chess fans and we wish you
all the best uh here at the chess gate
cup
thank you
thanks
a win in the Army Garden hey guys world
number four alireza firuja what a
performance by him and as he mentioned
he wasn't even expecting to make it true
he was ready he had other plans there
Daniel
have to cancel that dinner that day that
doctor's appointment whatever it is that
he's doing he's got more important
things to be doing right now he's modest
super nice but obviously he must be
thrilled he's just defeated Ali Reza
farouza he'll be on the cover of all the
magazines Dimitri callers and Jordan van
forests
performances by them absolutely two
underdogs score two big wins that's what
we love big upsets on day one and let's
take a look at our brackets and these
are the challenges going forward Dimitri
kodas will have to change his plans and
he will be playing Jordan run for this
the other big surprise of today Jordan
took down Hikaru Dimitri step down uh
Dmitry took down alireza farusha and
these two play against each other and
we've also got two Heavy Hitters Fabiano
caruana versus
David what starts out to you in this uh
day two of the Chaska Cup coming up well
it's not just the winners bracket Tanya
it's also the losers bracket the
elimination bracket Nakamura against
alireza ferrugia that is just gonna be
incredible both fighting for their life
now imagine one of those going home
after just day two that would be worth
the other final but uh we'll be keeping
an eye on that one as well obviously
and that's almost heartbreaking right
out of Hikaru and alireza one of them
will be knocked out tomorrow but of
course the action is not on only in
division one and we've got Jin to TM
back with us for his final thoughts of
the day Simon what's going on
yeah well there's been lots of action in
division one was uh well quite brilliant
wasn't it today loads of upsets and uh
let's now take a look at the other
divisions divisions two and three uh see
how things developed there so we have
first of all division two and um well
some shocks there as we spoke about last
time maybe biggest shocks manageroff
going out is one of the strongest
players in the world and also Dimitri
adri aching and so the winner of
division two gets a load of money ten
thousand dollars but also gets an invite
into division one and that's maybe the
most exciting thing and then we've got
all these games going on in division
three and even for a Grand Master who is
okay at maths it's quite hard to keep up
with them all but let's have a look
there's pages and pages of games and how
many great players there as well you've
got older players you've got younger
players you've got a fantastic mix of
generations and uh well there you go
that's the first page Sam Savion his
games today seem to be very impressive
if we're picking out someone for that
first page new Yang Yi is one of the
higher rated players out of everyone
garakamski won the first round there the
echo ponds one of ding's favorite plays
and let's also not forget Benjamin Bach
a famous streamer who's also a great
player and we'll move on to the second
round of the day now in division three
and again sounds Savion won that in
Armageddon so off to a very strong start
there and we've got Harry Krishna who's
a really Legend of Indian chess and the
last page on this uh busy division three
uh we see donanchenko coming back blue
bomb so it's a good day for Germany
today seemed like they did pretty well
and lots of people love David Navara
he's a sweetheart of the Chess World and
he won the second match there so uh yeah
it was exciting there was loads
happening and um well the actions can be
going on tomorrow and every day this
week so it'll be fun
it is Simon gonna be so much fun and as
you mentioned door points on the line
price money on the line the winner of
division two will play in division one
of the next Champions Chester but before
we wrap up I have to ask you we saw some
amazing action in division one today two
big upsets what was the highlight for
you
um I think the Highlight was just
Jordan's play
um Jordan played very exciting chess
he's a really exciting player and it was
a very tense match against Hikaru there
you don't often see Hikaru lose and uh
well tomorrow as David said Hikaru
versus Ali Razer and one of them is
going to go home crying and they will be
crying I don't know who it's gonna be
but that's gonna be worth tuning into
tomorrow uh that's the second chance but
their only chance so make sure you come
back and watch
elimination bracket they will be
fighting it out for their last life here
on the chess kid cup we've got a big
deal of action coming up tomorrow day
two will be on we will be back with all
of it we'll see you here same time same
place
Forest mate this is painful
resigns in a position Daniel you said
it's still game on
a big move
what happened
[Music]
foreign